Moin Leute, okay, jetzt muss ich meine Fake-E-Mail-Adresse anzeigen, meine Fake-Account, kapalul.com, da scheint es zu funktionieren.
Ich muss nochmal kurz meine Stream-Vorschau anmachen auf dem zweiten Rechner, sonst sehe ich nämlich nichts gescheit, außer jetzt hier gerade den Chat im Fullscreen.
Ja, ich bin gerade reingekommen vor 10 Minuten, ja, ungefähr, aber ich bin heute nicht die ganz große Runde gelaufen, es war echt ein bisschen kalt und irgendwie war es heute auch ein bisschen anstrengend, also insofern habe ich keinen Bock.
Heute nur 8 Kilometer, anstatt 10, reicht auch.
Back-Weight.
Wieder husten.
Nö, nö, nö, nix.
Kein Husten.
Nur, ich bin immer noch, wie gesagt, ich bin gerade draußen rumgerannt, da dauert das immer ein bisschen, bis man sich wieder dran gewöhnt hat.
So, also, ich muss gerade nochmal mein Vorschau-Rechner anmachen, er blutet gerade, noch was trinken schnell.
Ah, exzellent.
So, aus irgendwelchen Gründen geht...
...meine Maus nicht richtig auf der anderen Seite.
Ah, jetzt, okay.
So.
Ja, Leute, Dienstag, Mittwoch habe ich einen Teambuilding-Workshop, habe ich euch ja gestern schon erzählt.
Irgendwie habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock auf irgendwelche komischen, sinnlos Gruppenspiel-Aktivitäten, die eher nerven, als dass sie unterm Strich was bringen.
Hat irgendjemand schon mal so einen Teambuilding-Workshop gemacht und danach gesagt, boah, das war aber gut.
Das hat sich gelohnt, jetzt arbeiten wir viel besser zusammen.
Also ich noch nicht, zumindest alle, die ich bisher erlebt habe, nicht.
Aber der geilste Workshop, habe ich euch ja immer noch erzählt, habe ich euch ja gestern schon erzählt, ist der, wo wir gegen die Wand gespuckt haben.
Weiß auch nicht, wie sie auf die Idee gekommen sind.
Ah, viels Batman.
Ist super, ja, sehe ich auch so.
Die sind sehr sass, die sind nicht sass-k-ekriege, die sind einfach nur sehr...
...tragwürdig.
So, Vorschau-Rechner ist an.
Exzellent.
Chat gibt wieder Cringe-Jokes am Start.
Also, ich muss mal kurz die E-Mails ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, Arch Linux, by the way, PostChamp, kurz vor M, starten und Package-Updates machen.
Und ich muss immer noch ein bisschen drauf achten, ob vielleicht das Handy klingelt, weil ich bin immer noch, muss immer noch erreichbar sein auf der Arbeit bis Montag 7 Uhr, 7.30 Uhr.
Also, wir hatten auch mal, wir hatten auch mal einen Teambuilding-Workshop, aber das war noch, das habe ich sogar im Video erzählt, glaube ich, zum, ja, doch, doch, glaube ich, habe ich schon mal im Video erzählt, wo wir, ähm, neuen Chef gekriegt haben, als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe, kurz nach der Ausbildung, könnte sogar noch in der Ausbildung, ich glaube, es war sogar noch in der Ausbildung, ist schon ewig her, wo sie den Workshop gemacht haben, damit wir richtig geiles Team werden, dabei waren wir eigentlich ein richtig gutes Team.
Der einzige, der nicht reingepasst hat, zumindest bis jetzt, war der neue...
Der neue Chef, den sie uns hingesetzt haben, der hatte aber auch gefühlt überhaupt keinen Bock an der Position zu sein und dieser Teambuilding-Workshop sollte einfach nur, war quasi kein Teambuilding-Workshop, sondern Einführung quasi neuer, neuer Teamleiter und da gab es dann solche Fragen, das war richtig cringe, Alter, und die hätte ich heute wahrscheinlich auch nicht anders beantwortet, da gab es dann solche Fragen wie, ja, was würden Sie hier im...
Ich kriege es gar nicht mehr zusammen.
So sinngemäß war die Frage, was würden Sie machen, wenn...
Wenn was irgendwie kaputt geht und...
Ich kriege die Frage nicht mehr zusammen.
Zumindest ging es im Kern bei der Frage darum, wenn mein Chef mir was anderes sagt, als ich für sinnvoll halte, ob ich es dann trotzdem mache oder nicht, so, das war die Frage, ja.
Und da habe ich gesagt, naja, ich würde ihm erstmal sagen, dass ich es nicht für sinnvoll halte und ich meine, wenn er dann drauf besteht, dann würde ich vielleicht ein bisschen meckern, aber...
Letztendlich, wenn er die Verantwortung übernimmt, soll mir recht sein, ja.
Und je nachdem, ich habe halt auch gesagt, je nachdem, was es ist, also, wenn es jetzt darum geht, spring aus dem Fenster, dann nicht, aber wenn das was ist, wofür er die Verantwortung hat und dann haben die sich voll über...
Ich weiß nicht, ich fand die Antwort...
Ehrlich, Leute, ich kann bis heute an dieser Antwort nichts Falsches, nichts Falsches erkennen.
Ich, wirklich, also, seriously, erkennt ihr irgendwas Verwerfliches an dieser Antwort?
Also, ich bis heute nicht.
Zumindest haben sie sich damals übelst drüber aufgeregt, warum man das überhaupt in Frage stellt, was der neue Chef sagt und so.
Das habe ich euch ja auch mal schon im Video erzählt.
Eines der Gründe, eines der Gründe, warum...
Ich habe sie vielleicht nicht ganz so diplomatisch damals verpackt, okay?
Mag sein, mag sein, ja.
Vielleicht habe ich ein bisschen zu kurz und knackig aus...
Also, es ist halt sehr...
Ja, genau.
Wirkliche Antwort.
Haben sie übelst aufgeregt, warum ich das in Frage stelle, was der Chef sagt und sowas.
Ich habe auch gedacht, Alter, ihr habt es nicht mal...
Das war auch echt eines der Gründe, also eines der Mitgründe zu solcher Art von Workshops, warum ich damals da weg bin.
Das war richtig pepege, Alter.
Den Laden gibt es übrigens auch nicht mehr.
Da muss ich kecken.
Ich habe letztens die News gelesen, und letztens ist gut, glaube ich, vor einem Jahr oder so,
dass es meinen ehemaligen Ausbildungsbetrieb nicht mehr gibt.
Der wurde jetzt verkauft an irgendeine...
Boah, keine Ahnung.
Schweizer.
Also nicht verkauft, das stimmt nicht.
Der ist pleite gegangen, und die Reste wurden dann gekauft von irgendeinem Schweizer Rechenzentrumsbetreiber oder so.
Also ich finde das auch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Und ganz ehrlich, wenn du einen Chef hast, der nicht einfach nur Chef sein raushängen lassen will,
weil die sind meistens eh schlecht auf der Position,
sondern Interesse daran hat, dass das alles gut läuft,
für ihn und für seine Leute und für das Gesamtsystem,
dann hört er auch drauf, was die Leute sagen.
Die Leute sagen, die sich damit auskennen.
Und wenn er nicht darauf hört, dann kann er es zumindest begründen, warum er nicht drauf hört.
Zum Beispiel, ich kann euch was sagen, wo ich auch was gesagt habe,
wo man absichtlich nicht auf mich gehört hat,
aber das hat mich auch nicht aufgeregt, weil ich die Begründung gehört habe.
Und zwar, bei uns haben sie die ganze Zeit erzählt,
Max, Max, mach doch mal einen Call bei Google auf,
warum ein Kubernetes-Cluster so langsam ist.
Und da habe ich gemeint, ey, warum sollen wir da einen Call aufmachen?
Wir wollen den Kram am Ende eh nicht in Kubernetes betreiben.
Sollen wir jetzt doch irgendwie drei Wochen mit rummachen mit,
wir vergleichen Cluster, wir gucken die Version, wir machen Calls bei Google,
wir rufen da unseren Key-Account-Manager an.
Wir wollen es doch eh nicht so betreiben.
Warum machen wir dann da so einen Akt?
Ich finde es total sinnlos, da einen Ticket aufzumachen.
So, und dann haben sie gemeint, so, okay, Max, weißt du was?
Wir verstehen das, wir sehen es ja im Prinzip auch so,
aber mach trotzdem mal ein Ticket auf,
dass wir von Projektseite aus sagen können,
wir haben alles unternommen, was wir machen konnten.
Und wir sagen, okay, also, heißt im Endeffekt, wir sind uns einig, dass es sinnlos ist,
aber damit wir nicht schlecht dastehen, machen wir jetzt einen Ticket auf.
Ja, ja, so ist es.
Aber okay, ey, wenn ihr das wollt, ich mache einen Ticket auf,
aber ich sage euch gleich, bringen tut es nichts.
Kennt ihr solche Situationen?
Das finde ich dann auch okay, ja, das finde ich dann auch okay.
Das ist dann, das ist nachvollziehbar, dass man das machen will.
Das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass man so, seit wann steht da unten jetzt eigentlich Desktop 1 und Desktop 2?
Der stand doch die ganze Zeit immer nicht da.
Für Versicherung, genau.
Also insofern, das, wisst ihr, die Erklärung könntet ihr auch nachvollziehen, oder?
Also was heißt nachvollziehen?
Ihr findet es immer noch ein bisschen unsinnig, aber ihr versteht, warum die das machen wollen, ja?
Und dann sage ich auch, okay, ey, leuchtet mir ein, mache ich, ja?
Wie gesagt, es wird nichts bringen, aber ist okay.
Und das ist, das finde ich dann okay.
Da habe ich überhaupt kein Problem mit.
Also, hast du den Akara-Anwesenheitssensor ausprobiert?
Nein, immer noch nicht.
Ich habe den hier liegen seit drei Monaten oder so.
Hast du den nicht ausprobiert?
Würdest du dir von einem 18-jährigen Schulabbrecher als Chef etwas sagen, dass es nur...
Was?
Moment, das muss ich jetzt nochmal lesen.
Würdest du dir von einem 18-jährigen Schulabbrecher als Chef etwas sagen lassen, er ist nur Chef, der ab der...
Ey, wenn er die Verantwortung für das, was er sagt, übernimmt, klar, warum nicht?
Letztendlich ist er dann dran schuld.
Und wenn du der Sache nicht glaubst, dass er...
Dass er das einhält, was er sagt, dann lass es dir schriftlich geben.
Dann sag ihm, okay, also ich würde aus diesen und diesen Gründen halte ich das für keine gute Idee oder ich würde es so und so machen.
Und wenn er dann sagt, doch, du machst das jetzt, weil ich das so will, dann kannst du ihm im Zweifelsfall immer noch sagen, ja, okay, ich mache das, aber schick mir das doch bitte mal kurz schriftlich.
Und dann ist es okay.
Klar würde ich mir von dem was sagen lassen, wenn er die Verantwortung für das, was er sagt, übernimmt.
So haben wir das Recht.
Nein, ist ja noch besser.
Ist sogar besser für dich, weil wenn er das ein paar Mal macht und immer nur Scheiße entscheidet, dann ist er vielleicht doch wieder weg demnächst, ja.
Wichtig ist immer nur, wenn du Zweifel an sowas hast oder wenn sich schon rausgestellt hat bei den Leuten, dass die öfters mal Blödsinn erzählen und am Ende sich nicht mehr dran erinnern wollen,
sich das schriftlich geben lassen oder zumindest, wenn das aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht geht und du es vergessen hast, zumindest, dass du dir das schriftlich notierst,
wann das war und was.
Was er gesagt hat.
Weil das wirkt dann deutlich stichhaltiger.
An der letzten Firma, wo ich war, musste man sich mit sowas immer absichern.
Ich habe zum Beispiel auch oftmals so kleine Protokolle geschrieben bei irgendwelchen Besprechungen.
Entweder nur für mich oder ich habe es am Ende auch rumgeschickt, dass die sich dann nicht wieder so nach dem Motto, ja, nee, so war das doch gar nicht gemeint, aber das hatten wir doch so gar nicht besprochen, irgendwie rausreden konnten.
Das war in der alten Firma, wo ich war, ganz schlimm.
In der neuen glücklicherweise nicht.
Da habe ich das natürlich ein bisschen.
Aber in der Ausprägung nicht erlebt bis jetzt.
Naja, kommt drauf an, wie die das sagen.
Vielleicht ist es ja auch doof.
Ich meine, dann sollte man sich mal die, vielleicht, also je nachdem, wie die das sagen, ja.
Wenn die Leute hinkommen und sagen, alter, seid ihr kacke, hätte ich das jetzt mal vor fünf Jahren schon gemacht, dann würde das alles besser laufen, die unfähigen Kacknoobs.
Dann würde ich ihn auch fragen, ob er noch ganz dicht im Kopf ist.
Aber wenn er sagt, hier, das finde ich, finde ich aus diesen und diesen Gründen nicht optimal gelöst.
Oder nicht so gut, das mache ich ja auf der Arbeit auch, ja.
Und oftmals hatten wir es dann auch schon, ja, okay, ist was dran, aber es ist historisch so gewachsen aus den und den Gründen, es ist schwierig umzusetzen.
Das ist ja, das finde ich kein Problem.
Ich meine, vielleicht hat er ja recht.
Vielleicht hat er ja recht.
Vielleicht ist es auch wirklich doof, wie es bisher gemacht wurde.
Kommt halt drauf an, wie er es sagt.
Man kann, also man kann diese Aussage so und so treffen.
Das beste Beispiel ist immer noch jemand, den wir mal vorlesen.
Wir hatten früher im Team hatten, aus Russland, wir hatten mal drei Russen zwischenzeitlich, drei Kekomrits am Start.
Und einer von denen war super, ultra, der war schon, der war schon so freundlich, dass er kaum was gesagt hat, wenn, wenn, wenn, wenn was schiefgelaufen ist.
Das lief dann, Sylvie, danke schön für den Sub, das lief dann ungefähr so, ja.
Der saß, der saß rechts, rechts neben mir.
Und...
Dann hat er mich...
Also nicht immer, immer ist das falsche Wort, gar nicht.
Der hat ab und zu mal halt rüber geguckt.
Und wenn er halt zufälligerweise irgendwie rüber geguckt hat und ihm aufgefallen ist, dass das, was ich da gerade mache, Blödsinn ist.
Ja, zum Beispiel, so, keine Ahnung.
So, äh, also zum Beispiel, ich hätte jetzt hier irgendwie sowas, äh, irgendwie sowas geschrieben hier.
Cut, Süß, Keckel, äh, äh, äh, Reblul.
So.
Und Süß, und Süß, Keckel gibt's nicht, sondern Brock, Keckel.
Äh, hätte er gesagt, ah, Max, ähm, also er hätte nicht, der hätte, der hätte nicht gesagt, das, das ist Blödsinn, was du da machst.
Er hätte gesagt, ah, also, nee, erstmal hätte er gar nichts gesagt.
Erstmal hätte er gar nichts gesagt.
Erstmal hätte er mich circa 15 Minuten von der Seite immer wieder angeguckt.
Bis ich mich dann zu ihm umgedreht hätte und gesagt, äh, ja, was, was ist denn, was gibt's denn?
Und dann hätte er gesagt, also Max...
Es gäbe auch andere Möglichkeiten, das zu machen.
Oder sowas, sowas in der Richtung hätte er gesagt.
Also im Prinzip hieß das das übelste Blödsinn, was du gerade schreibst.
Es gäbe auch noch, oder, oder, was hätte er, ja, sowas in der Richtung hätte er gesagt.
Ja, es gäbe andere Möglichkeiten, das zu machen.
Also der war halt ultra vorsichtig.
Der hätte auch sagen können, Max, das funktioniert nicht, was du da gerade probierst.
Oder Max macht nicht so ein Mist oder so, ja.
Aber der hat das immer ultra vorsichtig ausgedrückt, so.
Also es gäbe eventuell noch Möglichkeiten, das auch anders zu machen.
So super vorsichtig immer.
Ja, das ist dann halt das Gegenteil.
Ups, jetzt habe ich den Chat-Git zugemacht.
Da ist er wieder.
Ich finde das auch gut.
Ganz ehrlich, mir ist das, mir ist das extrem lieber als das andere Extrem.
Das andere Extrem ist, Alter, ich weiß alles besser und erzählst dir die ganze Zeit, ohne dass ich es wirklich besser weiß.
Ja, genau so in der Richtung.
So in der Richtung.
Dann hätte er das gesagt, ohne Scheiß.
Man könnte das gegebenenfalls unter Umständen vielleicht auch etwas eleganter lösen.
Ja, ich glaube, das könnte eins zu eins von ihm kommen.
Ja, mir ist das lieb, wie gesagt, das Extreme ist mir lieber.
Es ist echt neu, dass da jetzt Desktop 1 und Desktop 2 steht.
Das finde ich eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Zumal man sagen muss,
das passt erstaunlich gut zu meinem Linux Dark Theme hier vom Terminal, oder?
Sieht fast aus wie die gleiche Farbe.
So, Leute, jetzt ist das vom Rennen endgültig wieder abgeklungen und mir wird es langsam ein bisschen kühl.
Ich mache jetzt mal die Heizung ein Stück hoch noch und ich hole mir mal kurz was zum Überziehen.
So, da bin ich wieder.
Lass uns doch mal gucken, was es auf Shithub so für Trends gibt.
Wir skippen wie immer AI, Machine Learning und diese Geschichten.
Weil langsam hängt es mir zum Hals raus.
Okay, Screenshot to Code, alles klar.
Drop in a Screenshot and convert it to clean HTML.
Was?
Wait, was?
Moment.
App converts a Screenshots?
HTML?
Tell me, CS?
Ah, okay.
Das analysiert was auf.
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich.
Das analysiert irgendwie mit GPT-4, was auf dem Screenshot drauf ist und dann generiert das HTML, CSS.
Okay, das ist extremely high IQ.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wann ich das brauche, ehrlich gesagt.
Also, ich bin mir unschlüssig.
Ja, doch, ich weiß wofür.
Das kann man wunderbar benutzen als Beispielplatzhalter auf Webseiten und sowas.
Ja, warum nicht?
Wie gesagt, so einen richtigen Anwendungszweck sehe ich gerade noch nicht, aber es ist cool, dass es sowas gibt.
So, AI ignorieren wir.
AI, Fokus, bestimmt auch AI, wenn ich das hier so lese.
Very good whiteboard, das kenne ich, das ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Ja, TL, Draw, da haben wir auch schon ein bisschen gedrawt und das hat es in Local Storage, heißt es im Browser, gespeichert.
Beispielanwendung AppFlowy.
Das ist...
Rust, blazingly fast.
Rust.
Gibt es das auch für Linux?
Ja.
Aber das gibt es nicht für...
Nicht für iOS, ne?
Oder ist das einfach Markdown, plaintext, File?
Ne.
Also alles, was es halt auch nicht für Mobile gibt, bringt mir halt...
Ach doch, es gibt es für iOS anscheinend.
Oder auch nicht, mal gucken.
So.
Dann haben wir...
Inferno Metal Shaders for SwiftUI.
Apple, Apple Krempel.
Okay, Apple Things.
Docker für Mac.
Ist Docker unter Mac besser als Docker unter Windows?
Weil Docker unter Windows ist richtig shit.
Potenziell würde ich vermuten, es ist besser, weil es deutlich Unix näher ist alles.
Aber so richtig sicher bin ich mir da nicht.
Spielst du das neue MW3 in Multiplayer?
Nein.
Ich habe mir MW3 nicht gekauft, ihr habt mir MW3 auch nicht kaufen.
Ich habe...
Ich habe ja eigentlich schon seit dem Reboot keinen Bock mehr so richtig drauf,
weil das wirklich an keiner Kreativität nicht mehr zu unterbieten ist.
Man sieht auch, dass sie absolut keinen Bock mehr auf ihr eigenes Game haben.
Es gab doch am Anfang diesen komischen Baum-Skin,
den man auf manchen Maps braun in braun überhaupt nicht gesehen hat,
habe ich auf Reddit gelesen.
Richtig dumm.
Es muss doch jedem mit ein bisschen Verstand im Hirn der Maps und Skins und Spielsachen-Design auffallen,
dass das eine dumme Idee ist.
Ja, ganz ehrlich, echt kein Bock mehr.
Ja.
Also man muss halt sagen, mich wundert es, dass es gescheit funktioniert,
weil prinzipiell, zumindest ursprünglich,
war Docker ja mal ein, im Prinzip ein Client für Linux-Container.
Und wie das Wort heißt, gibt es das auch nur unter Linux.
Natürlich könnte man, natürlich könnte man,
Docker, das CLI abstrahieren vom jeweiligen Container-Provider-Backend.
Vielleicht gibt es ja auch Docker für BSD-Jails oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Gibt es sowas?
Ach, tatsächlich.
Ne, ne, ne, ich habe immer noch nicht reingeguckt.
Das hat tatsächlich, habe ich gesehen, das Spiel halbwegs, halbwegs viele Spieler zur Zeit.
Wobei, ich glaube, es war zwischenzeitlich sogar mal Free-to-Play oder lange Zeit kostenlos.
Irgendwie spielbar oder im Game Pass oder irgendwas in der Richtung war da.
Deswegen hat das immer Steam Charts immer relativ viele Spieler gehabt in letzter Zeit.
Also es geht, das geht echt relativ gut.
Klar, relativ gut klar im Vergleich zu früher, ne.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es im Game Pass drin ist.
So.
Clashcore, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Archived, nice.
Latest version of, ah ja, alles klar.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was das ist.
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Aber Zeug, China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Das ist irgend so ein Kamera-Gedöns.
Habe ich mir mal angeguckt, hat mir nicht gefallen.
AI, das ist irgendwas für, ne, Machine Learning wahrscheinlich, ne.
Aha, was haben wir denn hier?
Waifu-Mode?
Was, was, was genau bin ich hier sehend?
Was sehe ich?
Ich traue mich nicht, ich traue mich nicht auf die, auf die Webseite zu gehen.
Was, was ist das überhaupt?
Waifu-Mode.
Okay, da kann man, da kann man irgendwelche Bilder generieren wahrscheinlich.
Waifu-Mode, activated.
Was es nicht alles gibt, ha.
So.
Kommen wir mal weiter.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier drin?
Udel, Udel-Book.
Die überspringen wir.
IPTV-Channels, ja, Flutter.
DIVI, AI, AI.
Blockchain-Gedöns.
Liest sich zumindest so.
Power Shell.
Aspire, das ist neues .NET-Zeug, wo ich jetzt ein paar Videos von geguckt habe, aber immer noch nicht so genau weiß, was es jetzt eigentlich ist.
Game-Zeug.
One Panel.
CN.
Ah, China-Chinesen.
One Panel, okay, irgend so ein Admin-Dashboard, was keiner braucht.
Also, ich nicht.
Und Machine Learning.
Das ist ja wirklich nicht sonderlich viel.
Wir gucken mal rein, was es in der .NET-Welt diese Woche neu gibt, weil die hatten ja ihr neues Release und ihre Konferenz diese Woche.
Aspire ist am Start.
Steam-Tools und UI-Blazer.
WPF, Alter.
Okay, immer noch besser als Mami.
Das ist so Dead on Arrival, Alter.
Microsoft und UI-Frameworks, Mensch.
So.
Welche, okay, Chat.
Was, welche Architektur ist das?
Wer ist Cleaner?
Adalis Clean Architecture oder Jason Taylor Clean Architecture?
Das ist jetzt hier die Frage.
Es scheint ein großes Bedürfnis zu sein von .NET-Programmierern, cleane Architektur zu machen.
Dass es da zwei Repos gibt mit 13.000, fast 14.000 Sternen beides.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Windows Optimizer.
Billy, Billy, Billy, Billy.
Ist das nicht das China-YouTube?
Avalonia.
Ja, immerhin mal ein gescheites Cross-Plattform-UI-Framework.
AI, Ding, was man nicht braucht.
Okay, nice, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Nope.
Hat jemand ein Sixth-Head-Empfinden, was man sich vor der FIAN-Prüfung nochmal anschaut?
Ich weiß nicht mal, was FIAN ist.
Fachinformatiker...
An...
Es ist nicht Anwendungsentwicklung, oder?
Weil das ist F-I-A-E.
Was ist...
Was ist Fachinformatiker?
Was ist FIAN?
Ist das eines von diesen neun, von diesen zwei neuen Fachinformatikern?
Wie, Vernetzung gibt's da noch?
Und, und...
Data, Big-Data-Zeug?
Ach doch, Anwendungsentwicklung, okay.
Ja, dann kann ich dir sagen, was du dir angucken sollst vor der Prüfung.
Und zwar das, was ich allen Fisis empfehlen kann.
Äh, nicht nur Fisis, allen Fachinformatikern empfehlen kann.
Einfach alte Prüfungen angucken.
Guck dir das an.
Guck, wo du dir die im Internet saugen kannst.
Du musst die ja offiziell...
Also offiziell musst du die kaufen, aber...
Du findest sicherlich auch andere Quellen, ja.
Kannst dir die irgendwo runterladen.
Guckst dir die Prüfungen an.
Und dann, ganz wichtig, die Ergebnisse dazu angucken, ob's passt.
Du musst einfach zwei Wochen lang vor der Prüfung regelmäßig Prüfungen machen.
Und wenn du da ganz gut abschneidest, dann easy.
Schaffst du ohne Probleme.
Es ist nicht so, dass die Abschlussprüfung schwer ist.
Das Schwierige an der Abschlussprüfung,
ist, du checken, wie die IHK dumme Fragen stellt.
Und die stellen dumme Fragen.
Vor allem sind die Fragen so dumm, dass du nicht verstehst,
was die eigentlich von dir wissen wollen.
Oder du denkst, es ist mehrdeutig, aber die IHK denkt, es ist eindeutig.
Jetzt dann?
Ja, aber das lag nicht an Rust.
So, das mal dicht.
Die IHK saugt.
Ja, die saugt richtig.
Oh, komm.
Und die Nux-Kiste mal wieder aus.
Die brauchen wir jetzt.
Ach, komm.
Lass mal an.
Schade auch nicht, ich hab genug RAM.
Mein Browser frisst noch nicht genug RAM.
Es muss unbedingt...
Ich brauch mehr.
Wie viel RAM ist belegt?
Ja.
Nix.
Guck mal.
Nur 41,8 von 67.
Keck, wait.
Also, ich mein ernsthaft.
Was soll das?
Das ist ja fast die Hälfte vom RAM noch frei.
Ich würd sagen, wir brauchen noch mehr Browser, noch mehr Tabs
und vor allem noch mehr VMs,
dass das irgendwie sich auch mal lohnt, 64 GB RAM zu haben.
Bist du schon mehr Entwickler als Admin,
also mehr DevOps als Ops?
Nö.
Also, im aktuellen...
Naja, je nachdem, wie man es...
Also, ich würd sagen, im aktuellen Job eher nicht.
Aber...
Also, im letzten eindeutig.
Im aktuellen Job vielleicht nicht.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, so richtig viel ganz klassisches Admin-Zeug
ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Also, es ist viel mehr Infra...
Cloud-Infrastruktur und Automatisierung.
Und ich hab ja auch schon die ein oder anderen Tools programmiert.
Unter anderem nen AMQP-Client in Go.
Also, ja.
So halbe-halbe, ja.
Aber ich sag's ja oft genug,
dass die Überschneidungen werden immer größer.
Das war irgendwas anderes.
Das war irgendwas mit...
Dass er mein Icon für die Seite nicht findet.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Das passt alles.
Also, es geht.
Es geht ja jetzt mittlerweile auch.
Hast du den RAM-Sparmodus aktiviert?
Wenn es Default ist, ja.
Ich hab da nix dran umgestellt.
Und es ist ja auch sinnvoll,
dass die Tabs, die du nicht aufhörst,
die du nicht aufgemacht hast seit 2 Monaten,
dass die nicht gleich automatisch in RAM geladen werden.
Das macht ja schon Sinn.
Echt.
Ja.
Übrigens, habt ihr's gelesen?
Manifest 3.
Die machen wieder einen neuen Anlauf mit dem Scheiß.
Das ist das, wo...
Wo uBlock nicht mehr richtig unterstützt wird.
Ja.
Letztens...
Das heißt, bald müssen wir alle wieder Firefox...
Firefox usen.
Achso, ach.
Sie haben...
Sie haben ein bisschen rückgerudert wieder.
Aber es ist ganz einfach, Leute.
Sollte Chrome es wirklich unmöglich machen,
dass man Adblocker verwendet.
Also, nicht, dass man...
Dass man Adblocker verwenden kann,
die gescheit funktionieren.
Dann ist halt
einfach wieder Firefox-Time.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre Firefox schlecht.
Ich hab Firefox drauf, ich hab Chromium drauf,
ich hab Chromium drauf.
Wenn Chromium, bau's hoffentlich dann wieder aus,
oder baut das andere wieder ein.
Aber eine Sache sieht man daran,
es ist gar nicht mal so geil,
wenn die gesamte Macht über so was
komplett bei Google liegt.
In dem Fall ist es halt, sagen wir mal,
nur YouTube und der Browser,
mit dem man guckt.
Aber es ist schon viel,
ja, viel sehr zentriert.
Du kannst dich bei Android und bei iOS
kaum noch dagegen wehren, quasi,
dich dem zu ergeben,
was dein Smartphone-Hersteller will.
Und hier hast du auch nicht viele Chancen.
Wenn halt
die Client-Software und die Plattform
vom gleichen Anbieter kommt,
da können die fast machen, was sie wollen.
Dass er da ein Video dazu gemacht hat,
wundert mich nicht.
Der ist ja immer am Start bei sowas.
Moin, Camille.
Wie wär's mit einem Linux-Desktop-Customization-Video?
Ich hab kein Desktop.
Ich hab...
Ich hab nen Terminal und nen Browser.
Und...
und nen Tiling-Window-Manager.
Und die Sachen, die sind relativ
einfach zu customizen,
weil da hab ich meine Config-Files dafür auf Shithub.
Also Desktop kann ich nicht
groß customizen.
Das customisigste bei mir
sind die Bilder im Hintergrund
und die...
und die Leiste
hier oben.
Stimmt, und außerdem haben wir...
Ne.
Achso, ja, das lag daran, das lag...
Das lag daran, weil das
so viel Daten geschickt hat, aber der Player
nie angefangen hat zu playen.
Das ging danach dann schon.
Hab ich ausprobiert,
alle fünf Varianten davon.
War okay, aber nicht so nice,
dass ich's behalten hätte.
Ich hab seit Jahren schon als Color-Theme
äh...
Tomorrow Night.
Base 16, Tomorrow Night.
Eher im Terminal.
Da hab ich mich so dran gewöhnt.
Nice.
Ja, also die Farben gefallen mir gut.
Vom Kontrast her ist es eigentlich genau richtig.
Und jetzt, seitdem ich mein Terminal
so halb transparent im Hintergrund habe,
find ich das auch nice.
Weil dann sieht man den Pepo durchgucken.
Übrigens, musste einer auch letztens
gezwungenes Windows-Update
machen, seitdem man hier auch die Desktop-Anzeige
kriegt. Und war bei jemand...
Also, war bei euch auch das Desktop-Hintergrund-Bild
weg? Heute Morgen?
Ich hab gestern Abend meinen Rechner runtergefahren, Windows-Update gemacht.
Und heute Morgen, ich hab gestern Abend meinen Rechner runtergefahren, Windows-Update gemacht.
Und heute Morgen, gestern Abend meinen Rechner runtergefahren, Windows-Update gemacht.
auf youtube encoded ja auf github auf discord man okay komm das kommen wir uns jetzt mal an
richtige hackerman content hier wieder ja das hatte ich auch schon da habe ich einfach sachen
die 15 jahre alt waren gelöscht und encouraging me to give google just a little bit of money for
looking at their plans these are actually not too terribly expensive and storage prices are
currently at historic lows so i could even buy myself a terabyte or so for a pretty reasonable
price but you know what's an even more reasonable price zero dollars so using a bit of software
engineering know-how i wisely traded tens of hours of my life and much of the sanity i had
left to avoid spending probably 50 dollars here's how i managed to store hundreds of gigabytes of
my files on discord for free if you're like me you have a lot of files and you're probably
getting pretty close to the free limits for icloud google drive if you're not already paying
for extra storage but i've been thinking aber ehrlich ich glaube früher oder später also das
diskon ist ja nicht blöd ich meine die kannte das auch feststellen und die also eine abfrage in ihrer
datenbank dürfte auch nicht so schwer sein falls sie dort eine datenbank abfrage für machen müssen
welche account so sort accounts nach storage lustet storage für free why and you water free storage
Jede Social-Media-Plattform ist wirklich nur ein Ort, wo du deine File oder Content aufladen kannst, wenn du möchtest, und andere Leute ansehen kannst, richtig?
Facebook, YouTube, Instagram, sie sind alle gleich. Du aufladest deine File und teilst sie mit Leuten.
Die wichtige Sache hier zu behalten ist, dass diese Firmen meistens Grenzen auf Filesize oder Quantität per Post setzen,
aber sie limitieren normalerweise nicht die Anzahl an Daten, die ein einziger User oder Account aufladen kann.
Und wir können diese Fähigkeit absolut verursachen, um so viel Storage wie möglich gratis zu bekommen.
Mein erster Kandidat für eine Plattform, um Storage zu stehlen, war YouTube.
YouTube lässt dir Videos gratis aufladen, und jeder kann 256 GB oder zwölf Stunden lang sein, was auch immer zuerst kommt.
Das scheint also eine solide Art zu sein, viele 256-GB-Gruppen von Storage zu bekommen.
Offensichtlich würde das nur für Video-File funktionieren, also brauche ich eine Art, all meine Daten, wie Word-Docs, Textfile, Bilder etc. auf Video zu konvertieren.
Ja, da gibt's ja schon was.
Storing Files on YouTube with a Script would probably work.
But there's no way around it.
There were a few drawbacks.
Some issues are that it's slow to convert to and from video.
It's also pretty slow to upload a video, wait for YouTube to process it, and then download it later.
The video file size ends up being several times the size of the original file.
But the big issue would probably be compression.
YouTube processes and compresses its videos to save storage, which is great for them, but potentially bad for being able to read my data later.
Compression could lead to losing some information and ultimately corrupt my files.
Hm.
The problems were probably solvable.
It would just make things slow.
Ja, deswegen ist es auch...
Wahrscheinlich hat sich das noch nicht so richtig etabliert.
I mostly just want to store a bunch of files I don't access frequently.
But I decided pretty early on to give up on the YouTube route because I realized there's a much better solution.
There's another service that lets you upload files for free.
It's called Discord.
You may have heard of it.
Sure, most people use Discords Text Chat and Voice Chat features to do boring things.
Basically, a CDN hat also das Text- und Voice-Chat.
... with friends.
But you can also upload files to Discord as message attachments.
Unfortunately, there's a 25 MB limit, but fun fact, one big file is really just a bunch of small files all put together in a row.
So all I need to do is split up my files larger than 25 MB into 25 MB chunks so that I can upload them.
And even though there are different types of files, like text, photos, videos with all sorts of file formats...
Never subbed, never donated, free storage, she baited.
... when it comes down to it, it's all just data.
As long as I have all the original bits of data in the right order and I know what the original name of the file was,
I can chop up any file into tiny bits, store them in Discord, then download them and reassemble the original file later.
So I got to work.
I created a Discord application in the developer portal and wrote a server in Node.js to handle uploading and downloading files from Discord.
Siehste? Das ist schon der erste Fehler.
Es ist nicht in Rust.
Also kann es nicht blazingly fast sein.
Discord.
I wrote a very basic frontend in React to give me...
Moin, warum hast du das Tab-Crooping immer noch an, weil ich es nicht ausgeschaltet habe?
... a simple way of interacting with the server.
When I want to upload a file, I can go to the frontend website and hit upload, like you would on any regular website that accepts file uploads.
The file is then transferred to my backend server, which splits it up into 25 MB chunks,
then uploads each chunk as a message attachment in a Discord server the bot has joined.
When the bot sends a file attached to a message into Discord, Discord publishes that message to the channel,
and replies to the bot with a unique ID of that message.
The bot keeps track of the message IDs of each chunk and stores them in a database with some extra information about the file,
like the original name, size and format.
Later, when I want to download a file, I can send the server the name of the file I want to download.
The server can then use the file name to look up which chunks are associated with that file,
get the message IDs of those chunks, and use the Discord API to download all those attachments.
Then it can put them all in the right order and write each chunk one after another back to disk,
with the original file name.
In this way we can upload and download files
Ziemlich gute Idee.
Sagen wir mal in Anführungsstrichen simpel, aber ne gute Idee.
Files of arbitrary size
Ich glaube halt nicht, dass es dauerhaft wirklich funktioniert, dass es Discord dauerhaft mit sich machen lässt,
aber, es ist jetzt nix wo man sagen würde super krass um die Ecke gedacht,
einfach nur einmal groß um die Ecke gedacht, dass man das ja machen könnte.
Ich glaube, dass die Umsetzung gar nicht so kompliziert ist.
Er könnte ein geteiltes Zip-Archiv machen, ist doch egal, ob er ein geteiltes Zip-Archiv
macht oder ob er die Dateien so splittet.
Wichtig ist nur, dass er sie am Ende wieder zusammenfügt.
Was er bei beiden machen muss.
Aber es gibt hier immer noch ein ziemlich großes Problem.
Privatsphäre.
Discord ist natürlich öffentlich, also kann jeder auf dem Server die Messungen und Attachungen
sehen, die der Bot sendet.
Der einfachste Weg, meine File privat zu halten, wäre es, einen Discord-Server zu erstellen,
wo der Bot und ich die einzigen Mitgliedern sind.
Und so würde niemand anderes mehr beachten können.
Das würde wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Obwohl jeder ein Attachement von Discord CDN downloaden kann, müsste man die exakten
Kanal-ID, Messungs-ID und sogar das Attachement-Name kennen, das mit einem Attachement verbunden ist,
um es richtig zu downloaden.
Das wäre ein guter Weg.
Was ich glaube, dass es ziemlich unwahrscheinlich ist, dass jemand selbst auswählen kann.
Aber es tut nicht schaden, extra sicher zu sein.
Selbst wenn niemand auf meinem Server ist, ist es hypothetisch möglich, zum Beispiel,
dass die IRS später dieses Jahr, wenn die Taxis kommen, ankommen und sie alle meine
sensiblen Tax-Dokumente sehen können, mit meinen Plänen, um Tax-Fraude zu verurteilen.
Ich möchte das natürlich nicht, also wäre es gut, meine Daten zu verstecken.
Glücklicherweise kann ich das ziemlich schnell machen.
Jedes Stück File, das ich encode, wird enkryptiert, dann, wenn ich das File zurücklese, kann
ich es decryptieren.
Da habe ich mir schon fast gedacht, dass so etwas jetzt kommt.
Ich habe es alles entdeckt, bevor ich es wieder zusammenlege.
Nun kann niemand sehen, was das Daten, das ich schreibe, tatsächlich ist.
Wenn sie die Messungen-Anbindungen anschauen, sehen sie nur eine Menge an randomen Symbolen
und Charakteren.
Nun, dass ich alles encodiert habe, ist das letzte, was übrig bleibt, um all meine Daten
zu uploaden.
Das ist nicht besonders schnell.
Nein, lass uns mal reden.
Zuerst muss ich das File durch meinen Browser an den Backend-Server uploaden, was ein bisschen
Zeit kostet.
Danach muss der Server das ganze File lesen, es in Trunks brechen und es enkryptieren, was
auch Zeit kostet.
Dann muss ich alle Trunks aufladen, um sie zu diskriminieren.
Das dauert sogar noch mehr Zeit.
Ich habe eine Status-Bar eingegeben, damit ich weiß, ob etwas tatsächlich passiert ist,
weil Uploads und Downloads mehrere Stunden dauern können.
Aber letztendlich habe ich alle File ohne zu viel Aufwand uploaden können.
Nun sprechen wir über die Leistung.
Wenn ich es auf ein Wort beschreiben müsste, wäre es...
Das ist lahm-ass-fuck.
Äh.
Ich habe einen Speedtest gemacht und für ein 55 GB-File dauerte es 2,5 Stunden, um zu uploaden.
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Das ist nicht so...
Das ist nicht so schlecht?
Das ist ungefähr 2 Minuten und 45 Sekunden pro GB, was definitiv langsam ist, aber nicht
wirklich zu schlecht, glaube ich.
Ja.
Die Downloads sind ein bisschen schneller.
Wir schauen uns ungefähr 1 Minute und 40 Sekunden pro GB an, um zu downloaden, was
wiederum ziemlich okay ist und wahrscheinlich viel schneller ist.
Leute, das wäre ja absolut nächstes Level.
Man könnte sich...
Okay, okay.
Passt mal auf.
Man könnte...
Die Dateien indexieren.
Man könnte sie indexieren in 4 KB Chunks und sich den Hash speichern.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Schad 256 Hash von 4 K Chunks und dann sich diesen Index speichern lokal und jede Datei,
die neu in den Server eingelesen wird, gucken, ob die identische Hashes hat, jedes Mal, wenn
du die in 4 K splittest.
Und wenn es identische Hashes hat...
Ja.
Wenn es identische Hashes hat, die nicht hochladen.
Dann musst du aber halt irgendwie das Ganze tracken, wo du welche Datei laden musst, an
welcher Stelle du extrahieren musst, dass du an den richtigen gehst.
Also das wird...
Das macht die Sache ultra kompliziert, aber gehen wird das Ganze und wahrscheinlich würde
es auch ein bisschen Speicher dann sparen.
... das Deeply Cursed Project really deserves.
In terms of data integrity and longevity, so far everything seems good.
It doesn't seem like any of my data has expired.
It's taken me a couple of months to get this all done and in that time, the first file
I uploaded for testing still downloads and decodes without issue.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, man müsste im Server jetzt noch einbauen, dass der für
jede Datei, so sagen wir mal, einmal in der Woche einen Download startet und abbricht,
dass Discord merkt, das File ist noch aktiv.
Ja, wahrscheinlich löschen sie es dann auch nicht, wenn sie merken, das File ist noch
aktiv.
Quick note here.
It's a few months later as I'm editing this and Discord just announced that they're
going to change how external CDN links work.
Because, believe it or not, people have been hosting malware on Discord.
Now, CDN links from outside of Discord will break after 24 hours, but links within Discord
will still function.
I'm planning a follow-up video after they make this change, because it's possible it'll
break what I'm doing here, but I actually think it might not, so keep an eye out for
that in the near future.
So, that's how I'm storing all my files on Discord.
Thanks for watching.
I hope you enjoyed my video, and I'll see you in the next one.
Deine Ritzp... Ritzp... Deine Ritzp-Stack.
Was ist das?
Chainsaw.
So, here is the...
The benchmark succeeds with...
Okay, das 6 in 30 Minuten, das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Aber ich lasse es mal auf.
Wie heißt dein Cursor bei Arch?
Habe ich das nicht committed auf Shithub?
Lass uns mal gucken.
Wenn nicht, so müsste ich es mal committen.
Cursor. Hier, da steht es doch.
Chatge.
Okay.
Bibata Modern Ember.
Heißt der.
Pog Cursor.
Cursor Größe 24.
Das ist kein Cursor, das ist ein Pog Cursor.
Ein...
Cursor.
Keine Ahnung, das kann man nicht zusammenfassen, die Wörter.
Pog, Pog Cursor.
Ne.
So. Aber der ist nice.
Und ich habe das absichtlich...
Auf Orang.
Weil ich habe ja überall Dark Theme und ich finde Orangen Cursor sieht man einfach gut.
Als auf dem Hintergrund so und dann machst du ja auch nichts.
Ich habe ja eh keinen Desktop, das heißt es macht gar keinen Sinn.
Es macht gar keinen Sinn für mich, hier auf dem Desktop rumzuklicken.
Außer mir den nicen Pepo, der gerade Cursors-Portal anzugucken.
Cursor Pepo.
Das ist die 3.
Dementsprechend ist es auch kein Wayland, weil Wayland in der VM nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Und sie sich immer noch am Blame-Gamen sind gegenseitig, wer jetzt die Schulter dran hat.
Okay.
Lul.
Warum kein Dualboot?
Warum soll ich Dualboot machen?
Ist doch viel besser, wenn ich live switchen kann zwischen Linux und Windows ohne zu rebooten.
Das ist quasi wie Dualboot, nur ohne Dualboot.
Quasi Dualboot less Dualboot.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Linux Tierlists.
Komm, wir, wir, wir geben uns jetzt die Linux Tierlist, allerdings ein bisschen, ein bisschen schneller.
Weil ich glaube nicht, dass wir...
7 und zwar ein Spiel.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, wie schnell er das, wie schnell er das macht.
We choose violence when we do a Linux Tierlist.
Das stimmt.
People get really upset, especially when...
Da, da, da gebe ich ihm recht.
Weil jeder meint, die Distribution, die er benutzt, ist halt das Beste.
Dabei haben die alle keine Ahnung.
Wir wissen alle, dass Arch-Dienungs das Beste ist.
Also wenn ihr was anderes benutzt und meint, eure Distribution ist das Beste, habt ihr objektiv gesehen Unrecht.
Korrekt?
Chat?
Any Archers?
Liste.
Korrekt.
Okay, auf geht's.
When it's an honest Tierlist about where you are in your Linux...
Gebe ich ihm recht?
Liste?
Der macht's richtig.
Ich, also, ich muss gleich dazu sagen, ja, dass ich bei solchen Tierlists eigentlich egal welche...
Letztens haben wir eine Tierlist gesehen, Programmiersprachen.
Das war, glaube ich, die unsinnigste Tierlist, die ich ever gesehen habe.
Die wichtigsten Sprachen nicht dabei und komplett bescheuert sortiert.
Ich glaube immer noch, dass das Video absichtlich gemacht wurde, um Leute zu triggern.
Ich stimme solchen Tierlists meistens nicht zu.
Gucken wir mal.
Aber dem Pick stimme ich definitiv zu.
Debian und Arch.
S-Tier.
Ja.
Debian auf dem Server.
S-Tier.
Arch auf dem Desktop.
Journey.
You're gonna learn a lot in this video.
I've already filled in the S-Tier.
It's Debian and Arch.
Nothing else goes in the S-Tier.
Debian, Arch, S-Tier.
Arch, when it comes to Linux Desktop.
Desktop?
Okay.
Ach, naja, was auch immer.
Ich würde es umgedreht sagen.
Arch auf dem Desktop, Debian auf dem Server.
Ubuntu auf dem Server geht auch, klar.
So wie auch meinetwegen Red Hat, wenn es unbedingt sein muss, wenn man auf Red Hat Bock hat.
Aber ganz ehrlich, genau das ist meine Kombi.
Server, Debian, Arch, Desktop.
Ich habe eine ganze Zeit.
Ubuntu Server verwendet, bis ich dann irgendwann den Grund überhaupt nicht mehr erkannt habe, warum ich Ubuntu verwende auf dem Server.
Früher habe ich Ubuntu gerne verwendet, weil die immer einen Ticken moderner waren als Debian.
Aber das ist zwar immer noch so, aber eigentlich nicht mal so richtig relevant.
Und Ubuntu hat einige Sachen, die mich abfacken.
Zum Beispiel Netplan oder Browser nur noch als Snaps.
Und ja, das fuckt mich auch auf dem Server ab.
Weil ich will zum Beispiel mal.
Trotzdem ein Firefox installieren für X-Forwarding oder sowas.
Aus Gründen, wo man es vielleicht mal braucht.
Aber das geht unter Ubuntu dann nicht gescheit.
Und Netplan ist eh die dümmste Idee ever, Alter.
YAML-Config für irgendwie IP.
Das ist so dämlich, Mann.
Also deswegen Ubuntu.
Deswegen bin ich irgendwann mal zu Debian geswitcht.
Vor ein paar Jahren wieder.
Für Serversysteme.
Und seitdem wüsste ich nicht, dass ich etwas anderes haben möchte.
Was macht denn Arch für dich subjektiv gesehen so gut?
Oh, da gibt es, da gibt es einige Sachen.
Also erst mal der Package Manager.
Das ist mit Abstand, ich habe jetzt leider keine Package mehr zum Updaten.
Das ist mit Abstand der schnellste und einfachste und beste Package Manager, den es gibt.
Du hast User Repos, dass du, also wenn es was nicht als ganz offizielle Packages gibt,
hast du User Repos, da kannst du zum Beispiel suchen nach kekw.
Okay, da gibt es nichts.
Twitch, irgendwas, was weiß ich da hier.
So.
Und da hast du tausend von User Repos.
Von Usern bereitgestellte Anwendungen, die du dir installieren kannst, die nicht offiziell
von dem Distributionshersteller kommen.
Aber du hast, ich glaube, ich würde mal behaupten, ich kann das nicht mit Zahlen belegen, aber
du hast für Arch Linux mit Abstand die größte Package Auswahl, die es gibt.
Es gibt eigentlich fast nichts, was es nicht gibt für Arch Linux.
Und das ist die Kombination.
Also du hast ein super Paket Manager.
Du hast alles Software, die du brauchst.
Du hast modernste Packages.
Du hast modernste Kernel.
Du hast modernste Software-Versionen.
Du hast ein super Customizable-System.
Und eigentlich, deswegen ist Arch Linux das Beste.
Also auf dem Desktop, auf dem Desktop.
Okay.
Also auf dem Server sieht es für mich anders aus.
Ich mag auf dem Server Debian am liebsten.
Debian aus den Gründen, die, glaube ich, der Chat auch gerade schon genannt hat.
Debian ist stabil.
Debian funktioniert.
Debian ist bei allem irgendwie supported.
Debian hat mittlerweile auch alles dabei, was man braucht.
Zum Beispiel haben die mittlerweile auch ZFS und sowas dabei.
Haben wir letztens auf der Arbeit sogar erst gebraucht,
weil wir zu wenig Storage hatten.
ZFS.
Und Debian funktioniert einfach.
Und eine Sache, die ich noch nie hatte bei Debian,
bei anderen Distributionen schon, ist,
dass bei einem Update irgendwas kaputt gegangen ist.
Bei mir ist legit, bei Debian.
Ich weiß nicht, Chat, wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Bei mir ist unter Debian noch nie irgendwas bei einem Update kaputt gegangen.
Noch nie.
Das ging einfach immer.
Red Hat hat es schon auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Ubuntu erst recht.
Ja.
Debian noch nie.
Also es gibt, ich kann mich nicht an einen Fall erinnern,
dass Debian irgendwann, irgendwie mal kaputt gegangen ist.
Noch nie.
Ja.
Also.
Deswegen.
Deswegen finde ich, wir waren übrigens gerade mal beim Video gucken.
Deswegen gebe ich ihm da voll und ganz recht.
Debian, Arch Linux, S-Tier.
Arch auf dem Desktop, Debian auf dem Server.
Ja, es gibt schon so ein, Chat, Moment hier.
Ja, es gibt schon so ein paar Sachen.
Da muss man sich dran gewöhnen.
Aber ist doch kein Ding.
Installierst du nach und gut ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ich musste letztens auf der Arbeit diskutieren,
ob wir nicht TMAX als Default-Paket auf alle unsere Server draufhauen können.
Da kam der Erste um die Ecke und meinte,
oh nein, aber Screen reicht doch.
Ja, als würde jetzt irgendwie so ein 50-Kilobyte-Package Probleme machen.
Gut, sollen sie machen, was sie wollen.
Also, das finde ich nicht so schlimm,
dass Curl nicht drauf ist,
WGAT nicht drauf ist bei dem einen und bei dem anderen.
Muss auch immer gucken, was man für Images verwendet,
wenn du beispielsweise die Debian-Cloud-Images verwendest.
Die sind super minimalistisch.
Und mal gucken, ob der 4M-Champ noch funktioniert.
Gucken, gucken, ob es auch klappt.
Ja.
Das ist ein Debian 11 Cloud-Image.
Das ist halt super minimalistisch.
Dementsprechend lässt sich das auch schnell runterladen.
Und da ist halt nichts drauf, standardmäßig.
Also, gut wie nichts.
Mr. S. N. Alive, danke für den Sub.
Also, da ist nichts.
Aber das Gute ist, es ist ein minimal lauffähiges System.
Und du kannst es halt customisieren.
Deswegen finde ich Debian, wenn du mich fragst,
ich mag Debian als Base für Container-Images auch lieber als Alpine.
Alpine hat ja bekanntermaßen öfters mal DNS-Probleme.
Ja.
Genau.
Aber Alpine hat ja öfters mal DNS-Probleme.
Und Debian ist ein...
Das ist so No-Brain.
Du kannst Debian benutzen, wenn es geht.
Guck mal.
Ich meine, wenn du hier mal drückst,
es ist halt nichts dabei.
Curl...
Doch, guck mal.
Curl ist beim Cloud-Image standardmäßig dabei.
Wer hat erzählt, dass Curl nicht dabei ist?
Curl ist dabei.
Weget ist auch dabei.
Also, Leute.
Wenn bei dem Cloud-Image Curl dabei ist,
dann kann es nicht so super minimalistisch sein.
Heck, wait.
Welche VM benutzt du?
VMware Workstation.
Ja, das macht bei DNS-Auflösung öfters Probleme.
Da gibt es regelmäßige so Heul-Threads auf Reddit.
Wenn mal wieder irgendeiner, frag mich nicht,
fünf Megabyte DNS-Antworten hat,
dann kackt Alpine wieder richtig rein.
Ist Tmux auch dabei?
Nee, glaube ich nicht.
Nee, das nicht.
Ist Screen dabei?
Screen ist dabei.
Ich weiß auch, warum Screen dabei ist,
weil Apt verwendet mittlerweile Screen,
wenn du Sachen upgradest oder installierst.
Apt install Tmux.
Guck, das hier ist Screen.
Deswegen ist das, glaube ich, Screen mittlerweile dabei.
Gut, dann löschen wir die Debian VM mal wieder.
Benutzt ihr Monitoring-Software auf der Arbeit?
Welche hast du?
Ich kann nicht lesen, Alter, Leute.
Ist wieder schrecklich gerade.
Benutzt ihr Monitoring-Software auf der Arbeit?
Wenn ja, welche?
Ich glaube nicht, dass es da Probleme gibt, wenn ich das sage.
Ich schreibe gerade eine 15-seitige Hausarbeit über das Thema
und würde mich mal freuen.
Also, es gibt ja zig Sachen, die man verwendet.
Also, ich muss die Antwort jetzt leider ein bisschen länger machen.
Angefangen habe ich mal mit Nagios.
Das war noch während der Ausbildung beim Provider.
Nagios.
Und ihr kennt mich.
Ich habe immer noch ein weiches Herz für Nagios.
Ich würde nicht unbedingt zwangsläufig einen neuen Nagios heutzutage aufsetzen wollen.
Aber ich mag Nagios.
So, Nagios.
Dann haben wir Zabbix gemacht.
Und in letzter Zeit hauptsächlich Prometheus.
Allerdings muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen, Prometheus ist gut für Metriken.
Man kann damit quasi auch alles andere monitoren.
Aber merkt irgendwie permanent, dass es dafür nicht gemacht ist.
Für so Is-up, Is-down, Port-off, Port-to.
Das geht mit Prometheus.
Aber Prometheus musst du sehr viel selbst stricken.
Das geht mit sowas wie Nagios oder Zabbix oder Checkmk.
Checkmk ist übrigens auch das, was wir auf der Arbeit zurzeit zwar nicht ausschließlich,
aber zumindest größeren Stil verwenden.
Zabbix ist auch komplett insane.
Das Problem an Zabbix ist, dass die Logik hinter der Config kann sein,
dass man hinter der Config keine Sau kapiert.
Nicht mal die Zabbix-Leute verstehen ihre Logik.
Ich habe mal irgendeine Zabbix-Release-Version, Ankündigungsvideo gesehen von denen.
Zabbix kommt ja aus Lettland oder Litauen oder so.
Kommen die, glaube ich.
Und fällt mir nur gerade ein.
Und der Typ hat das in dem Video gezeigt.
Und da wusste er selbst in dem Video nicht, wo er klicken muss in seine Webinterface.
Also Zabbix-Webinterface, ich kenne niemanden, der das Zabbix-Webinterface checkt.
An sich finde ich Zabbix wirklich nice.
Zabbix integriert nahezu alles, was man braucht.
Leider halt super weird Webinterface um zu konfigurieren.
Und das was Graphen angeht und Dashboards ist halt Grafana immer noch meilenweit besser.
Es wäre halt mega, wenn Zabbix da ein bisschen aufholt.
Muss ja gar nicht auf das Niveau aufholen von Grafana.
Dann wäre Zabbix und vielleicht mal ein ordentliches Webinterface auf die Reihe kriegt,
was irgendwie ein bisschen logisch ist.
Dann wäre Zabbix wirklich wunderbar geeignet als so gerade auch im Heimbereich
und sagen wir mal, wenn es jetzt nicht so super groß wird,
Bereich als einzige Monitoring-Lösung, wo man sonst nichts mehr dabei braucht.
Ja.
Ich habe mit der neuen Nagios-Version gar nicht so viele Erfahrungen.
Ich kenne die alten noch aus Zeiten, wo Nagios Net Saint hieß.
Das war quasi so 1999 oder so.
Fragt mich nicht.
Nagios.
Wikipedia.
Moment.
Seit wann hieß das so?
Net.
Ja.
Net Saint hieß das früher.
Ich glaube, da gibt es gar keine Version History.
Wann haben die das umbenannt?
Das ist, das ist uralt.
Net.
Ja.
Weiß man nicht.
Das, das, das war, das war auch schon ein bisschen vor meiner Zeit.
Aber wir hatten noch einen Nagios, der noch, also der hatte noch einen Net Saint im Einsatz damals.
Uptime Kuma finde ich eine super Geschichte für Leute, die Sachen daheim selbst hosten.
Das einzig Blöde an Uptime Kuma für mich ist, dass so ein paar Features, die ich gerne hätte, mir fehlen.
Nämlich, ich hätte gerne sowas wie, zeig mir an, wenn die Festplatte im Wohnzimmer vollläuft.
Das kann Uptime Kuma nicht.
Uptime Kuma ist genau für das da, wofür es da ist, nämlich simple Checks zu machen.
Host, Up, Down, Ping da, Port da.
Leider kann man auch keine Remote Checks gescheit ausführen, dass man sagen würde,
äh, wobei ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es mittlerweile die Möglichkeit hat, über sowas zu machen.
Ich, vermutlich nicht.
Ey, Push Monitor suckt.
Face in Custom Function.
Ja.
Das ist blöd.
Und man hat auch keine History und sowas.
Also für einfache Up, Down Checks top.
Aber spätestens so wie, ich würde gerne sehen, ob meine Festplatte vollläuft oder vielleicht auch mal gucken,
wie die den letzten Monat über vollgelaufen ist.
Kannst du damit nicht machen.
Deswegen, ich habe daheim auch Zabbix im Einsatz, weil ich keinen Bock habe auf mehrere Lösungen, auf mehrere Sachen.
Aber Zabbix ist abfuck.
Ich mag Zabbix nicht.
Aber es ist das einzige, was so als, ja, All-in-One-Lösung gescheit bei mir funktioniert.
Wie ist deine Software auf der Arbeit?
Prometheus, ja?
Ah, ne.
Auf der Arbeit.
Checkmk haben wir da.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich finde Checkmk nicht so geil.
Kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Willst du eher Metriken auswerten?
Oder willst du eher so alte klassische Up, Down Checks machen?
Also willst du zum Beispiel gucken, ist der Port offen?
Antwortet der Web-Server?
Pingt die Kiste?
Steht in der Web-Response irgendwas drinne?
Dafür ist Checkmk und Zabbix und sowas ganz gut.
Willst du Metriken einsammeln?
Ja.
Metriken können zum Beispiel auch sein, wie ist der Verlauf von meiner CPU-Last über mehrere Monate?
Oder gar beispielsweise.
Wenn du Anwendungen überwachen willst.
So bei irgendeiner Java-Anwendung.
Wie sind die Garbage-Collector-Runs?
Da ist Prometheus einfach unschlagbar.
Ja.
So.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Eigentlich wollte ich mich da gar nicht so sehr drüber auslassen.
Jetzt gucken wir mal das Video mit der Linux-Tierlist weiter.
So.
Halten wir mal fest, ich stimme ihm komplett zu.
Debian Archilux-S-Tier.
Weiter.
Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab, müsst ihr das mal mit nwublos in Chat schreiben.
Nobody can debate this.
I just wanna-
Korrekt.
Und gerade, wir usen Arch, by the way, das lass ich auch nicht debaten.
Es gibt manche Leute, die sagen, es muss Gentoo sein.
Wir haben ne Arch-Linux-Gruppe auf der Arbeit.
Ja, aber da sind nur drei Leute drin.
Wir kriegen auf der Arbeit ja Windows vorgesetzt.
Und was für ein Windows, Leute.
So ein verhunztes Windows hab ich selten gesehen, ey.
40.000 Viren-Scanner im Hintergrund.
Alles ist super langsam, man.
Ich arbeite nur noch auf meiner Linux-VM.
Ja, du kennst das, ne?
Ich arbeite nur auf meiner VM.
Alles andere halte ich nicht aus.
Okay, ich rate, Leute, ich rate mal, in Evil geht wahrscheinlich nur Red Hat bei ihm.
Garantiert packt er, äh, nicht Evil, Devil, Devil.
Kommt aufs Gleiche in dem Fall raus.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es dieses Tier nur gibt, damit er Red Hat reinpacken kann.
You can get out of the pointless tier.
Let's explain the tiers real fast to break it down.
Amazing for new users, these are your noobs, just fresh, coming from like Windows or Mac
or some other operating system.
They don't know anything.
Ich kenne niemand, der von, der überzeugter Mac-User war und zu Linux gewechselt ist.
Think about Linux, typically this is where I point them.
And most people will move on from the amazing tier.
Also bei mir ist umgedreht.
Ich bin Linux-User und hab eigentlich gar keinen großen Bock drauf, Mac zu usen.
Wenn ich die Auswahl hätte, Windows oder Mac, würde ich eindeutig Mac benutzen.
Aber ich kenne niemanden, der zufrieden mit Mac war und gesagt hat, ich will jetzt Linux verwenden.
Some people will not, and that's okay.
Für mich persönlich ist es deutlich angenehmer.
That's for business, kind of self-explanatory, business distributions.
Creative and unique, these are distributions that are kind of around, but they are so unique
that nobody really uses them, or the real niche.
Okay, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, wir verstehen's.
Ich glaube, wir verstehen's, um was es geht.
I'll label those as such.
Auf geht's.
Let's get into it, not waste any time.
Alma Linux.
Das ist das Logo von Alma Linux.
Hätte ich nicht erkannt.
Also Alma Linux und Rocky Linux sind ja die neuen CentOS'e, also quasi Red Hat Nachbauten,
freie Red Hat Nachbauten, die quasi Red Hat Logos und das Gedöns entfernt haben.
Was hat Rocky, Leute, seht ihr Rocky Linux hier?
Das müsste auch irgendwo sein.
Ich kenne das Logo von denen nicht.
Rocky Linux.
Okay, dieses komische Häkchen.
Seht ihr das hier irgendwo?
Grünes Häkchen?
Vielleicht hier hinter ihm so.
Best for Business.
Ja, gäbe ich ihm recht.
Gäbe ich ihm recht.
Also Desktop juckt mich das nicht.
Aber Best for Business, würde ich auch sagen, viele Businesses stehen auf Red Hat und viele machen ja den Trick, was ich eigentlich auch sehr, sehr schlau finde und wahrscheinlich Red Hat nicht mag, aber ich würde es auch so machen.
Die machen ja den Trick, dass sie ein paar Red Hat lizenzierende Systeme haben.
Und der Rest ist CentOS, Alma, Rocky und wenn dieses Systeme irgendein Problem hat, dann wird versucht, das Problem auf einem der offiziell lizenzierten Systeme nachzustellen und dann ein Ticket bei Red Hat aufzumachen.
Falls man es braucht.
Die meisten Tickets, egal ob es Microsoft, Red Hat oder Oracle oder noch schlimmer SAP, Google, was auch immer es ist, die meisten Tickets sind meistens ziemlich, ziemlich useless und da gibt es eine Standard Response und das bringt nichts.
Ja, aber Best for Business.
Ja, aber Best for Business unterschreibe ich, weil viele Software auch zertifiziert ist nur für Red Hat kompatible Systeme, also für Red Hat und beziehungsweise dann auch für Red Hat kompatible.
Offiziell meistens nicht, aber haben sie meistens keine Probleme mit.
Best for Business.
Ja, gäbe ich ihm recht.
Ist ein 1-1-Equivalent von Red Hat.
Red Hat ist der Teufel.
Ich wusste es, ich wusste es.
Diese Kategorie, ich wusste es, diese Kategorie gibt es nur, dass er Red Hat reinpacken kann.
Sie haben CentOS zerstört.
Ja.
Sie haben es von Downstream nach Upstream gemacht.
Also CentOS war damals komplett anders.
Fun Fakt, CentOS war mein erstes Linux-Distributionssystem.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, warum man CentOS noch verwenden sollte jetzt.
CentOS-Stream ist nicht CentOS.
CentOS-Stream ist eine beschädigte Version, die Red Hat nachdem sie ihn gekauft haben, umgekehrt hat.
Sie haben vor kurzem ihren Sourcencode geschlossen.
Viel Dramatik da.
Ich werde nicht darauf eingehen.
Aber das ist der Grund, warum diese in der Devil-Tier enden.
Und kontroversiell.
Fedora endet auch hier.
Ehrlich?
Ich mag Fedora nicht.
Also für mich vollkommen okay, dass er das da reinsteckt.
Ich bin begeistert.
Wir haben schon sechs Linux-Distributionen, sechs Linux-Distributionen eingerankt.
Und Fedora kann man sich vielleicht drüber streiten.
Aber bis jetzt stimme ich tatsächlich komplett zu.
I actually recommended Fedora this past year.
I thought the releases have gotten so much better.
And then I was like maybe, maybe that CentOS 8 drama.
Ich mag Fedora nicht.
Also die kann er ruhig in Evil packen.
Fedora makes it into here, especially this week, with them proposing opt-out telemetry.
So Fedora is in the Devil-Tier.
Nothing I'd ever recommend using anymore.
Opt-out telemetry?
Was ist mit denen los?
Was ist denn mit denen los immer, Alter?
Na gut, Red Hat halt.
Everything from Red Hat kind of goes into here.
Why we got people mad from the Red Hat crowd?
Let's just upset the Ubuntu people.
Let's just toss Ubuntu in here.
Come on.
Naja, okay, komm.
Das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Ich hab auch meine Probleme mit Ubuntu, ja.
Ich find Netplan ist unglaublich dämlich.
Wer hat sich ausgedacht, Netzwerkkonfiguration über YAML?
Wer will Browser nur noch über Snaps haben?
Gerade auf dem Server ist das übelst doof, falls man X-Forwarding machen will oder sowas.
Aber insgesamt muss man echt sagen, ja, die haben auch viel komisches Zeug da.
Ja, die haben auch viel komisches Zeug gebaut.
Ja, gerade ihre komischen Versuche mit eigenem Display Manager und Composite-Window-Gedöns und sowas.
Die machen viel weird, weird, weird Champ-Shit.
Aber insgesamt, gerade wenn man sich mal anguckt, also Ubuntu hat ja schon eine ganze Zeit lang wirklich pioniert, auch Linux auf dem Desktop.
Also ich würde die gar nicht so wirklich mehr in, ich würde die nicht in Devils stecken.
Ich würde Ubuntu mittlerweile tatsächlich in Best-for-Business einkopieren.
Weil gerade wenn du Cloud-Server betreibst, ist Ubuntu enorm beliebt.
Und vielleicht auch für Noobs auf dem Desktop, ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich würd's nicht mit Devil ein. Das stimme ich jetzt nicht zu.
In this one word.
App install Firefox.
Actually, that's three words.
But one command, I should say.
Okay, er spielt auch auf Snaps an.
Okay, ja.
Snaps sind dämlich.
Why does that change it to a Snap?
What's up, Ubuntu?
You've just gone from this great OG original...
Dieser Müll mit Snaps fuckt mich auch ab.
Aber trotzdem, ich würde Ubuntu, gerade weil die Support anbieten und auch im Azure generell im Cloud-Umfeld recht beliebt sind,
ich würde tatsächlich das als noch die bessere Alternative, wenn man Support haben möchte, zu Red Hat sehen, ehrlich gesagt.
Also Best-for-Business würde ich Ubuntu reinpacken.
Ich seh's jetzt allerdings aber auch aus Desktop- und Serversicht.
Rein aus Desktop-Sicht ist eigentlich Ubuntu fast schon Pointless, wenn man Mint nehmen kann und sowas.
Mittlerweile, was ja auch auf Ubun...
Wobei, basiert die noch auf Ubuntu oder auf Debian mittlerweile?
New friendly distribution to just stay the hell away from it as far as Desktop goes.
You'll still see Ubuntu unlike Servers.
And they do have some kind of business-esque Server-type thing.
But this is Linux Desktop we're talking about.
Nobody really wants to use Ubuntu anymore and that's why it makes it in the double tier.
Okay.
Next we got Alpine Linux.
Ah!
Das ist das Logo von Alpine.
Endlich nicht erkannt.
Okay.
Alpine Linux ist auch so ein Ding.
Alpine Linux ist gerade aus dem Container-Umfeld eigentlich kaum noch wegzudenken.
Okay, ich gebe zu, ich bewerte das jetzt ein bisschen anders als er, aber ist ja auch blöd, wenn ich bei allem immer nur sage, stimme ich zu.
Also aus dem Container-Umfeld kaum noch wegzudenken.
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss,
mir sind Debian-based Images lieber als Alpine-based Images, weil bei Alpine-based Sachen öfters auch mal was kaputt ist.
Insofern,
ich würde es nicht in Pointless stecken, es ist einfach viel zu verbreitet.
Ich würde es vielleicht in Creative & Unique packen, Alpine.
So mit ihrer Nicht-Lip-C-Geschichte und Minimalansatz.
Vielleicht, vielleicht hier rein.
Definitiv nicht in Supreme, aber auch nicht in Evil.
In Lightweight, Lightweight oder Creative & Unique.
Würde ich Alpine reinpacken.
Best for Business, naja.
Da gebe ich ihm recht, was er sagt, aber ich würde es trotzdem anders einkopieren.
Was? Was? Antics? Kenne ich nicht.
Chat, kennt ihr Antics?
Wann kommt Linux Mint? Weiß ich nicht, da ist es. Man sieht es schon.
Wann das kommt? Keine Ahnung.
Was für ein Ding!
Was? Ach, Arco! Ja, äh, Pointless, glaube ich.
Haben wir das nicht auch mal ausprobiert, Chat?
Und ich wusste auch nicht, wofür es gut sein soll?
War das nicht irgendein Arch, war das nicht irgendein Arch-Linux mit vorkonfiguriertem Desktop-Kram?
Ja, würde ich, da würde ich mit Pointless fast mitgehen, Leute.
Da sind wahrscheinlich einige stinkig.
Ja.
Arco-Linux ist in der Pointless-Tier.
Ich liebe ihr Git, ich stehle viel von Arco.
Sie haben so viele coole Kustomisierungen.
Und sie machen einen tollen Job, den neuen User zu fühlen, wenn er zu Hause ist.
Das Problem ist, es ist auf Arch.
Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn du nicht weißt, wie man Arch installieren kann,
und du nicht weißt, wie Arch innerlich funktioniert ...
Wobei, wenn ich ehrlich sagen muss, offizielles Arch-Linux ist,
ist super-easy geworden seit dem Installer.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, hieß das Ding Arch-Setup oder Arch-Install?
Das ist quasi Terminal-Installer.
Das ist jetzt sicherlich nicht so ein Polished-Installer, wie das Ubuntu hat,
aber damit kommen die meisten halbwegs da.
Also Arch installieren mit dem Installer ist super-easy,
da brauchst du eigentlich keine extra Distro mehr für.
Be in an Arch-Distribution.
It's not just an Arch-Distribution,
it's not to downplay any of the contributions they make.
And I like to steal stuff from Marco all the time.
It's really kind of cool.
But at the same time, I don't think the distribution should exist.
Those people, those talented individuals over there,
should move on and probably just re-contribute to upstream Arch.
You know?
Because Arch is what makes this possible.
And you can just take the customizations they make
and put it into Arch.
And you better understand it,
and you'd be less likely to...
Ich hoffe, er packt Suse in Pointless.
Dann würde ich es zumindest hinpacken.
Break. So...
Wahrscheinlich packt er es aber in Business.
Now that we've said that, there's a bunch of distributions,
we kind of need to toss them here along with that same explanation.
Okay, let's go.
Manjaro. What happens with Manjaro?
Ich gebe ihm recht mittlerweile.
Ich habe es eine Weile benutzt, ich gebe ihm aber mittlerweile recht.
Wait a second. It has some of the best customization.
Titus, noobs can install Manjaro in Arch.
Same problem, right?
The noob will go to the AUR.
They will download a bunch of crap and they will break Manjaro.
I know, because I did it.
And honestly, Manjaro itself, even though...
Man muss ja sagen, dass die ganzen Arch-Linux-Fans
gar nicht sagen würden, dass Manjaro ein Arch-Linux ist.
Chad, ist Manjaro ein Arch-Linux oder nicht?
Geht das...
Darf man sagen,
I use Arch, by the way, wenn man Manjaro verwendet?
Also ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube nicht.
Weil Manjaro hat zwar Zugriff auf die Arch-User-Repos,
aber hat eigene Repos für die Standard-Software,
die quasi so ein bisschen zwei Wochen Verzögerung haben zu den Arch-Repos.
Was eigentlich von der Idee her nicht verkehrt ist,
um zu wissen, dass es eben etwas stabiler ist.
Aber ich habe mit Arch auch so gut wie keine Probleme
und zunutze mache ich von meiner VM einen Snapshot,
wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Haben wir da installiert.
Aus welchem Grund haben wir da einen Snapshot gemacht?
Egal, ich delete den mal, ich glaube nicht.
Ach, HA-Proxy haben wir installiert.
Unsinnig.
Man braucht keinen Snapshot für, zack.
Alles klar, mal ein bisschen Platz aufräumen.
Also, ihr seht das auch, so dass man das nicht sagen darf, ne?
Arch, by the way.
The main Dev over at Manjaro is very talented.
Manjaro is very talented as well.
The problem with it is,
hell, I remember in 2019,
I just did a Pac-Man-SYU to upgrade the entire system.
Und dann war es kaputt.
It broke, because I didn't read the patch notes.
Die hatten doch letztens das Problem,
wobei das nicht Manjaro das Problem hatte,
sondern war das Arch,
die mit Krupp, mit Krupp gab es doch ein Problem,
dass da irgendwas nicht richtig generiert wurde
und das System nicht mehr gebootet hat.
Da war doch vor so einem Dreivierteljahr ungefähr was.
It should have been like a S-Y-Y-U-C
oder so eine andere Art von Upgrade-Path.
Und weil ich es nicht nach dem entsprechenden Patch gemacht habe,
hat es mein Manjaro gebrochen.
Das sollte nicht passieren.
Es sollte nicht passieren. Manjaro sollte nicht existieren.
Und wenn du diese Art von Expertise benötigst,
dann solltest du Manjaro nicht benutzen.
Du solltest nur das Supreme, Arch Linux, benutzen.
So ist das, wo das ist.
Nun, ich denke, Arctics ist ein ganz besonderes Beispiel.
Ich denke, Arctics ist ein ganz besonderes Beispiel.
Keine Ahnung, habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Moment, hatten wir Arctics?
Ach, Antics hatten wir vorhin, okay.
Die verwenden nicht SystemD.
Okay, das könnte für einige Leute ganz nice sein,
die immer noch keinen Bock haben auf SystemD.
Ist nicht so, dass ich der allergrößte SystemD-Fan wäre,
aber ich habe mich mittlerweile daran gewöhnt.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Kann ihr ClearLinux?
Ich werde ClearLinux in Creative Unique drücken,
weil es eine wirklich tolle Distribution von Intel ist,
aber ich würde sie nie als Desktop verwenden.
Es ist wirklich schnell, wenn man einen Intel Chip hat,
dann sieht man, dass es oft etwas höherer ist als viele andere Linux-Distributions.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist seltsam, weil der Package Manager, SwapD,
wirklich schwer zu arbeiten ist.
SwapD.
Erzeugen in ClearLinux ein Dev-Bereich ist nicht das Spaßigste.
Erzeugen in ClearLinux ist nicht das Spaßigste.
Wenn man sich schwer an Flatpak verwendet
und man hat ein immutables System,
das nicht so viel verändert,
ist es fast unmöglich, ClearLinux zu brechen.
Es ist genug unangenehm.
Ich liebe, wie sie jeden Teil von Systemd verwenden.
Sie benutzen nicht mal FF-Tab
für Mounting Drives,
sie benutzen Systemd-Auto-Mount.
Sie waren eine der ersten Distributions,
die Systemd-Boot benutzen.
Ich benutze glaube ich auch immer,
Systemd-Boot in meiner VM.
Bin mir da nicht so sicher.
Es ist definitiv kein Grub, was ich verwende.
Was ist das?
Ist das Systemd-Boot?
Ja? Okay.
Dann verwende ich auch.
Ich war voll intuitiv.
Innovativ.
Intuitiv ist es in dem Fall sogar auch.
Weil man nicht allzu viel machen muss.
Hallo? Okay.
Alter, VMware!
Was ist los mit euch?
Irgendwie hat das gerade
so ein paar kleine Probleme.
Leckt auch ein bisschen.
Scheint es wieder zu gehen.
Next.
So it's unique enough to where I'm like,
you know what, I like what they're doing.
Muss an Systemd liegen, ja.
ClearLinux kind of goes in that creative,
unique category for me.
Deepin.
Ah, Deepin.
Das ist das China-Chinesen-Linux, gell?
Das ist das China-Linux.
Da muss ich sagen, ich fand,
wir haben das ja mal ausprobiert on stream,
ich muss ehrlich sagen,
von den nicht so
mainstreamigen Desktop-Dingern,
die wir mal ausprobiert haben,
fand ich Deepin, mal unabhängig davon,
dass es ein China-Linux ist,
ich fand das
nicht schlecht.
Ich fand das nicht übel.
Es machte tatsächlich einen ziemlich
runden aus
einem Guss Eindruck.
Alright.
Let's keep going with that. It's pointless.
Now, people are like, wait a second, Deepin's
a desktop environment. It's amazing.
Titus, what's wrong
with your head? I'm like, okay.
Don't worry. Deepin
is an amazing desktop environment.
It has some of the best scaling. It's great.
But as a distribution, it's
kind of pointless.
Man sollte Deepin am besten auf Arch installieren
und dann ist alles gut.
KDE Neon, das ist die
Live-CD von KDE, oder? Wo man neue
Versionen mit ausprobieren kann.
Glaube ich. Da würde ich nicht
sagen, dass es pointless ist, sondern
für diesen einen Zweck ist es wahrscheinlich
ganz gut.
I know I love KDE.
Ich nicht.
Ich kann KDE nicht ab.
Elementary OS fand ich mal
eine Zeit lang für Noobs ganz nice.
Das ist Elementary.
Das ist Elementary, ja.
Ich würde es aber mittlerweile
auch da reinschmeißen.
Ich finde es auch nicht mehr sinnig.
Also gerade für Noobs
fand ich mal Elementary
wirklich nice. Vielleicht würde ich es
auch noch da oben reinpacken.
Them making a distribution to go along
with the desktop environment
doesn't make any sense to me.
Just go grab a good
distro that's a base.
Ist doch so. Ist doch so. Ist doch so.
Ist nicht sogar
elementary Debian
oder Ubuntu based.
Go right here. Because what happens
when you start forking off of these
because all three of these
are Debian forks, which
come from, you know, Ubuntu is a fork of
Ja, dann machen die doch, das was er sagt.
Debian and then it forks off of Ubuntu into these.
That's a fork of a fork.
Going all the way to upstream.
There's many things they do and then
they're like, oh crap, we probably should
come back into these and grab
these fixes. It just gets messy.
And I just don't like that.
Like, why wouldn't you just use the
OG Debian? I just don't
understand it. Debian's gotten so good
over the past couple years that I just
don't see a purpose to these
distributions. I like the contributions.
I like the desktop environment.
But it's where it kind of falls
for me. In that same realm, we got
Endeavor and Groobit
too. Let's just grab both the
first base spins, really cool
customizations, huge amount
of programs, same
problem as Minjaro. We're gonna
kind of leave it there.
Farin OS. Was?
Was? Moment, das hab ich noch nie
gehört. Wie heißt
das? Sieht aus wie Twitter
OS. We're gonna kind of leave it
there. Farin OS.
Moment.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie man das
schreibt. Harin OS?
That's
this one. Used to have a really good
place years back when your
Debian installer was not very good
and it looked kinda like crap. Keine Ahnung.
Nie was von gehört.
Why? Why does it exist?
Same thing.
Gentoo. Oh, die coolen Leute
sagen natürlich Gentoo, ja.
Gentoo. Okay, geh ich mit.
Geh ich mit. Ja, okay.
Gentoo's great at building
your own Linux kernel. Let's say you wanna make
where I would like
the world to go with Gentoo. Ja, also
ich geb ihm recht, Creative und Unique
passt ganz gut. Ganz ehrlich,
die Zeiten von
ich kompiliere mir meinen Krempel selbst,
wozu? Wozu?
Man hat zwar heute vielleicht die Rechenpower
dazu, aber es macht eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Wir hatten mal
einen auf der Arbeit, auf der
letzten, der hat
Gentoo benutzt und er wollte
das sicher in der VM installieren. Der musste
dreimal neu installieren, bis er das
VMware-Netzwerk-Kernel-Modul
reinkompiliert hatte.
... ist Kiosks and
let's say that menu at your favorite restaurant.
Seeing like Windows blue screens
of death when I'm going into like a big
high-rise building, I'm like, why
is this using Windows?
Why isn't it just using like a
stripped-down version of Linux that will never
break? That's where Gentoo comes in.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht in der Liste
drin. Create it to do one thing
and do it amazingly and then it'll never
change. It'll be really
minimal. Ich glaube Slackware und sowas ist da auch
nicht drin. Just very secure. So,
Gentoo
is amazing for custom
versions, where you can
de-bloat the Linux kernel, build it yourself
and then have a couple packages that are really
easy. Using it as a daily driver,
that's really for try-hards and people that
just have a lot of time on their hands.
So for Gentoo, I just...
So nach dem Motto, jemand schickt dir
per E-Mail-Anhang, was ja
heutzutage noch vorkommt, ein Word-Dokument.
Erst mal OpenOffice selbst
kompilieren, Moment, Sekunde, 45 Minuten später.
... in the creative
unique category because of that.
Now this one is gonna cause a lot of people
to be mad and originally I was
really concerned because
when it comes to security... Okay, pass
mal auf, ich predicte jetzt mal was.
Ich sage euch mal was dazu.
Also, ich finde Kali an sich ist
eine gute Sache. Du hast halt
alles schon vorhin erzählt, den kannst du ausprobieren, aber
ich verwende Kali Linux so gut wie nie,
weil, wenn ich irgendwas
von den Tools brauche, kann ich
sie einfach nachinstallieren.
Das ist eher sowas für
ich habe es auf dem USB-Stick drauf,
wenn man es mal braucht oder sowas.
Ich bin jetzt da auch nicht der
große Security-Guru,
aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen,
die Male, wo ich Kali Linux verwendet
habe, beispielsweise zum
abgreifen von
der Fiat-App im
Android-Emulator, bisschen Traffic abgreifen
über Man-in-the-Middle, Proxy,
da habe ich erst Kali benutzt,
bis ich dann festgestellt habe, es ist viel
einfacher, den Proxy sich
einfach unter Arch zu installieren und
die Android IDE und das da drüber zu machen.
Also,
ich persönlich
habe nicht den großen Anwendungszweck für Kali.
Wenn man sowas auf dem USB-Stick hat,
weil man was Komplettes
in der Tasche haben möchte,
zum ausprobieren, dafür ist es bestimmt gut,
deswegen würde ich es wahrscheinlich in
Creative & Unique packen.
Ist für Pentester
ganz gut.
Ja, so stelle ich mir das auch vor.
Also, insofern,
wahrscheinlich würde ich es in Creative & Unique packen.
In Security Researchers out there,
in Ethical Hackers,
Kali Linux, oh
man, they
really love their Kali Linux.
But guess what?
It's absolutely pointless.
They just have a whole bunch of pre-installed
programs. Yeah, they have like
some gimmicks like Windows Mode
and stuff like that, but really,
if you're going into Security Researching,
you need to learn the fundamentals.
You need to learn networking.
Naja gut, aber wenn du irgendwo bist,
wo du keinen Netzwerkzugang hast,
um mal ein paar Packages nachzuinstallieren,
ich glaube, ein Kali Linux auf USB-Stick
ist gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ich würde es in Creative & Unique packen.
Auf jeden Fall nicht in Pointless.
You need to learn all these things
and you should be using
its upstream of Debian
and installing those things specifically.
Da gab es mal Ärger.
Ein Kollege von mir auf der letzten Arbeit
hatte einen ganz normalen Proxy,
wo man ins Internet rausgegangen ist
und auf einmal standen irgendwelche Security-Leute
bei ihm auf dem Platz, warum er irgendwelche
Hacker-Tools runterlädt.
Die haben in ihren
Proxy-Logs nur gesehen,
dass der halt bei alter Packages gezogen hat,
sich all die ganzen Kali-Packages
gezogen hat und da sind halt auch
von
Passworts,
Hash-Crack-Dingern,
Proxy, SSL,
Fake-Sachen und so weiter alles dabei.
Und da standen die direkt bei ihm,
ja, WLAN, Zeug, alles.
Standen die bei ihm auf der Matte, sagen sie,
warum er sich die ganzen Hacker-Tools da ziehen würde.
Wie? Was soll denn der Typ machen,
wo wir uns letztens das Interview von angeguckt haben?
Wir haben uns
doch letztens so ein Interview mit einem Hacker
angeguckt. Was macht der denn, wenn es
kein Kali-Linux mehr gibt, Mann?
Erinnert ihr euch noch daran?
Das war doch...
Ich krieg's gar nicht mehr zusammen.
Das war doch der Typ, der irgendeine
5 Jahre alte
Software von Github sich gezogen hat,
da irgendein in Anführungsstrichen
Schwachstelle drin entdeckt hat
und dann erzählt hat, er hat irgendwie
highly secure Medizin-Software
gehackt oder sowas. Da muss ich mir echt
an den Kopf greifen, Mann. Ja, der hat
ja...
Ja eben, deswegen würde ich's in
Creative und Unique packen, wenn man einfach
was Fertiges braucht. Wenn ich ein bisschen
was längerfristiges brauche, ja zum Beispiel
als ich
diese... das Home Assistant
Add-On
programmiert hab, was über die
Fiat-API-Sachen abgefragt hat,
wo ich mal in der offiziellen
App Netzwerktraffic mitschneiden wollte,
um zu gucken, was die eigentlich macht.
Das hab ich auch erst unter
Kali-Linux probiert, hab's dann aber
ganz normal die Software, die ich dafür brauche,
unter in meinem Arch installiert, weil ich da halt auch
meine Entwicklungsumgebung und alles
zum Programmieren hatte. Das war für mich einfach,
wenn ich einfach mal kurz und knackig was brauch.
Wie gesagt, ich würd's nicht in Pointless packen, ich hätt's in
Creative und Unique gepackt.
Ich würd's einfach in Parry installieren.
Parry ist eigentlich, glaube ich, besser als
Kali, es ist ein bisschen leichter.
Wait, has a lot of the same toolset,
but less of the gimmicks, less of the bloat.
So a lot of security researchers actually end up
on Parry instead of Kali. So I'm
more worried about me saying
Parry's in the Pointless tier
based on everything I just said.
I'd still put them in the Pointless tier
and that's not good for my own self-preservation
because there's many talented people that do
use these distributions, but honestly
Was ist denn das? Sieht aus wie das KDE-Logo.
They probably
should just use Debian.
So, that's where I kinda put these ones.
They do have really good toolsets, but
at the end of the day, it's just
Also sieht aus wie das alte KDE-Logo.
It's all stuff that
you could easily add to
Ach, Kubuntu
ist das!
Okay. Oh, da hatte ich mal
einen, der hat voll geschwört auf Kubuntu.
Ihr wisst, ich bin kein KDE-Fan,
also
Supreme Distro.
Also, wenn's nach mir geht, geht
KDE, geht das in Pointless.
Gibt es mehr Linux-Distributionen
oder JavaScript-Frameworks?
Es gibt verdammt vieles von beidem, aber
JavaScript-Frameworks gibt's definitiv
mehr. Wahrscheinlich seit der Stream
angelaufen ist, vor einer Stunde 40
Minuten, wurden schon fünf neue JavaScript-Frameworks
created.
Zumindest.
Ich nicht.
Ich mag KDE nicht.
Für neue Benutzer, vielleicht.
Ich...
Ich mein, ich kann den Pick...
Ich mag KDE einfach nicht.
Also, wenn's
nach mir geht, wird es in Pointless wandern.
Ich mag KDE nicht. Aber das, was
ich mag, würde kein Einsteiger
je verwenden unter Linux.
Du kannst...
Seriously, Leute.
Setzt dem Einsteiger mal das hier
vor. Der wird sich denken, alter,
was will der von mir?
Das ist ein schwarzer Kasten im Fullscreen.
Und...
Und wenn ich rechts klicke, passiert nix.
Und wie
starte ich überhaupt Sachen? Ich hab keine
Taskleiste. Ich kann... Oh!
Oh, ich hab nen Browser. Okay, da...
Also, das kannst du dem Einsteiger
auf jeden Fall nicht vorsetzen.
Aber ich...
Ganz ehrlich...
I3 ist das einzige, was
ich verwenden kann auf'm Linux-Desktop,
weil es das einzige ist, was mich nicht
nervt. Ich mag...
Gnome nicht.
Wobei manche sagen, Gnome aussprechen.
Ich mag Gnome nicht. Ich mag
KDE nicht.
Ich mag...
LX-Dingsbums
nicht.
XFCE geht noch irgendwie, wenn's
unbedingt sein muss. Mag ich aber auch nicht.
Ich mag...
Was haben wir denn noch?
Budgie nicht.
Ja, Hyperland kenn ich. Das läuft leider in der
VM nicht. Ich mag eigentlich
nix. Sway kann ich nicht
benutzen. Sway kann ich nicht benutzen.
Ich würde tatsächlich sogar
Sway benutzen. Aber Sway
kann ich nicht benutzen, weil Wayland in der VM
nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Und sie mal wieder
die alte Nummer fahren,
sich gegenseitig zu blamen, wer jetzt
dran schuld ist. Also, Wayland
funktioniert prinzipiell schon mit den
passenden Settings, aber es ist nicht so einfach.
Mittlerweile, immerhin,
immerhin kann man mittlerweile
Wayland in der VM einfach installieren
und Fenster resizen
funktioniert danach. Was nicht funktioniert
ist Screen Refresh. Also,
wenn ich Wayland in der VM installiere, da drin
Sway starte, refresht mein Screen nicht.
Was im Endeffekt heißt,
also, wenn das Screen nicht
refresht... Ich mein, ich kann halt
nix machen, weil
das Screen refresht nicht. Und das einzige,
um den Screen Refresh zu bekommen,
muss ich auf die...
Ups.
Muss ich auf die Konsole schalten und zurück auf den
Desktop, dann refresht das Screen wieder.
Das ist ein Bug. Gibt es
bei VMware und bei Wayland
gibt es Tickets, aber beide Seiten
sagen, das müssen die anderen fixen.
Und man kann es ja irgendwie fixen, weil
neue Ubuntus
beispielsweise mit Wayland in der VM
auch funktionieren, aber ich hab keinen Bock drauf.
Und mein i3 funktioniert einfach zu gut,
als dass ich's irgendwie ändern will.
Aber das kannst du
keinem vorsetzen hier, was ich da hab.
Also, das... Ich geb ihm
schon recht, ich glaub für Neulinge ist das gar nicht
verkehrt. Ich persönlich mag
nichts auf dem Desktop, außer
i3. Und ich mag auch
an i3 nicht wirklich i3.
Was ich an i3 mag, ist,
dass es nicht da ist.
Ich hab...
Guck mal.
Ich mein, ich hab kein Desktop.
Ich hab
ein Terminal im Fullscreen und ein Browser im Fullscreen.
Und je nachdem, was wir dann machen,
hier ne IDE im Fullscreen und noch
ein Terminal oder so.
Normalerweise...
sieht das bei mir ungefähr so aus.
Ja. Zack.
Je nachdem.
Ja.
Und hier vielleicht noch für die
Website zum Test noch ein Chrome. So.
So ungefähr sieht das...
Hallo? So ungefähr sieht das bei mir halt aus.
Und ganz ehrlich,
i3 ist halt einfach
nicht im Weg. i3 macht halt nix.
i3 geht mir nicht auf den Keks.
Deswegen i3.
Und für...
Zum Starten...
Das ist Rofi.
Da hab ich auch so ein paar
Probleme mit, weil's mich manchmal nervt.
Am Großen und Ganzen funktioniert's ganz gut.
Und das war's.
Aber allein schon, dass du Shortcuts brauchst,
um Sachen zu starten,
blickt ja schon keiner.
Das ist wie zum ersten Mal Wim aufgemacht.
Wie komm ich wieder raus?
Ich mag an i3 am ehesten,
dass es...
dass i3 nicht im Weg ist.
Ich brauch auch kein Desktop mit Icons
und nix.
Okay, aber für Einsteiger lass ich mir's gefallen.
Ist okay.
So gentle for the Windows-User coming over.
You should move past Kubuntu,
but from a KDE-Perspective,
I think it has some of the best...
Was? Redox-OS?
Oh, ist das dieses Rust?
Ist das dieses Rust-OS?
Diese Rust-Geschichte?
Ja.
Moment, kann man das
wirklich benutzen? Läuft da irgendwas drauf,
um es
sinnvoll benutzen zu können?
Überhaupt?
Hat das nen Browser?
Ja gut, vielleicht hat das geschafft
Firefox dafür
zu cross-compilen
oder so irgendwie.
Okay, ich schreib mir das mal auf.
Wir können das ausprobieren.
Ich muss ja...
Redox-OS...
besser als erwartet.
Ich bin mir da nicht sicher.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es wirklich was für
man kann es täglich benutzen taugt,
aber ich lass mich da gerne eines Besseren
belehren. Okay, weiter.
Leute, ich hab sinnlosen Spam gerade
gekriegt auf meiner...
auf meinem
Firmen-Dienst-Handy.
Übelsten, übelsten
Scam, alter.
Willkommen. Ich weiß gar nicht, woher
haben die überhaupt meine Telefonnummer?
Ich verwende dieses
Handy für nichts.
Außer für, ich kann angerufen werden.
Aber
mich haben da auch schon irgendwelche
Shops aus Österreich und so drauf
angerufen, also wahrscheinlich hatte die Telefonnummer
schon mal jemand
vor mir.
Ultrasinnlos Spam habe ich bekommen.
Willkommen.
Wir haben festgestellt, dass Ihr
Werdegang und Ihr Lebenslauf von mehreren
Online-Personalvermittlungsagenturen
empfohlen wurde.
Deshalb möchten
wir Ihnen einen Teilzeitjob anbieten,
den Sie in Ihrer Freizeit
ausüben können. Unsere
Aufgabe ist
einfach.
Wir bewerten einfach Ihre Lieblingshotels.
Es gibt keine
zeitliche Begrenzung. Sie können
die Beurteilung zuhause durchführen.
Der Tageslohn
liegt zwischen 300 und 1000
Euro. Ja, alles klar.
Alle Löhne werden
am selben Tag ausgezahlt.
Wenn Sie teilnehmen möchten,
kontaktieren Sie uns bitte
per WhatsApp.
Ja,
alles klar.
Block. Moment, wie blockt man
jetzt hier Leute gescheit?
Äh.
Ähm.
Info?
Anrufer
blockieren. Kontakt
blockieren.
Und
und
löschen.
Delete.
Löschen und melden kann man auch machen.
Spam löschen und melden.
Okay, nice. Machen wir das mal.
Alles klar.
Ich würde sagen, ich sollte ins
Hotel-Business einsteigen.
Okay, er findet Kubuntu ganz
toll, habe ich verstanden.
Jetzt kommt Linux Mint.
Okay, das würde ich,
warum ich einen Screenshot gemacht habe.
Ich habe einen Screenshot gemacht,
weil ich am Montag mal gucken will,
ob das nicht irgendein Phishing-Versuch ist
von unseren Security-Leuten.
Die machen auch manchmal sowas.
Ich wollte mal fragen, ob noch jemand
das gekriegt hat.
Linux Mint würde ich persönlich tatsächlich
hier oben auf Amazing Funny New Users packen.
So wie ich den kenne,
weil man anstatt Linux Mint auch einfach
Ubuntu oder Debian verwenden könnte.
Ich würde es Amazing for New
Users packen. Ganz ehrlich,
Linux Mint ist das Ding, was ich jedem
ans Herz legen würde, wenn er neu einsteigt.
Ja, okay, gut, stimme ich zu.
Ich check auch nicht, warum Ubuntu in
Devil gelandet ist.
Hey, die meisten neuen Benutzer kommen rüber,
oder vielleicht setze ich etwas,
wie mein Großvater, wo ich sage,
die größte Augenweide ist Linux Mint
jetzt nicht,
aber ich finde,
es funktioniert gut
und es kommt einem auch erstaunlich wenig
in den Weg.
Also, wenn ich nicht happy wäre
mit meinem i3 Setup,
würde ich wahrscheinlich Linux Mint fahren.
... wie mein Großvater, wo ich sage,
hey, du brauchst nur einen Webbrowser,
du willst nicht infiziert werden, und du willst nur
arbeiten.
Ich würde Linux Mint fahren, weil
es so intuitiv ist, es gibt Grafik,
Tools für alles.
...
... ...
ist das? Ach, MX-Linux, ja, das ist komplett pointless. What? What? Haben wir das nicht
sogar mal ausprobiert und ich fand es komplett unsinnig? Moment, Moment, Moment, ich bilde
mir ein, wir haben das mal ausprobiert, das war komplett, das war komplett unsinnig. Was
ist das für ein Thumbnail? Die AI hat wieder zugeschlagen. Hier, MX-Linux haben wir da
ausprobiert, ja, ich fand es komplett unsinnig, MX-Linux. Nein, ich denke gar nichts. Weiter
gucken. Warum Fedora, das verstehe ich auch nicht genau. Also für mich ist okay, ich
mag Fedora auch nicht. Ja, okay, gut, MX-Linux gehe ich mit, habe ich auch nicht.
Ich habe auch den Sinn nicht verstanden von MX-Linux. It's just, I don't see a point
in installing it these days. Was ist das? Ah, das ist NixOS, ich wollte gerade sagen
NixOS, das Logo, habe ich gerade am letzten Drücker noch erkannt. NixOS ist eindeutig
creative und unique. Wir können nicht sagen best for business, ich kenne niemanden, der
es businessmäßig verwendet, aber es ist definitiv creative und unique. Just did a
video on it, it's reproducible builds for Linux. You can install anything, reproduce
1000 computers. Obviously best for business. PC-Linux-OS is one thing that was kind of
interesting, you know, four or five years ago PC-Linux-OS could make it into like the
amazing community of users because it used a lot of compatibility. Let's see, you had
a webcam that didn't work, you could use PC-Linux-OS and it might work, where Debian
might not. But these days it hasn't seen many updates in I think several years now
and I just can't recommend it and it ends up being the pointless tier because it's
everything it used to do real well. Debian does now, so there's no point in it.
Peppermint, same thing, lightweight. I would say Peppermint has a little bit better package
selection than Ubuntu. That's why it makes it in a lightweight realm for me. I really
like it. Das ist Puppi-Linux, das haben wir auch mal. Ich weiß nicht, für was wir das
mal benutzt haben, auch wo wir was ultra-lightweight-mäßiges gebraucht haben, aber das ist so haarig zu
bedienen.
Okay, kommt ja gleich noch. Pop OS. Okay, auf was basiert Pop OS? Das haben wir auch
ausprobiert, das haben wir auch ausprobiert. Ich fand es persönlich auch unsinnig. Er
packt es bestimmt auch in Pointless. Ich fand es auch unsinnig.
Das sieht ziemlich Stock-Desktop-Gnome aus, das ist ja noch schrecklicher als Customer.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich gebe zu, ich mag KDE nicht, aber ich bin hin und her gerissen dazwischen,
was ich weniger mag von den großen Sachen, weil ganz ehrlich, Gnome, ich gehe nicht,
ich bin nicht d'accord mit der Gnome-Design-Philosophie. Du hast doch nicht mal Minimieren-Button
an den Fenstern mittlerweile, weil das bloated ist. Das musst du dir erst um drei Ecken wieder
einschalten. Und bei meinem i3 habe ich auch keinen Minimieren-Button, aber da minimiere
ich auch keine Fenster. Also ich mag Gnome überhaupt nicht und ich, ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich
wäre mir sogar noch KDE lieber. Ich mag die neuen Gnomes nicht.
Evolved yet into...
another tier. I could totally see this coming back to here, or maybe even right
here with the Cosmic toolset. They're moving on from GTK. They just haven't yet. And all
they have going for it is like an Nvidia Spin that's good, but to me, it's pointless
right now. But as Cosmic comes out and it becomes more unique and there's actually more
stuff that's just not copies with some tweaks, because, you know, hey, Pop! OS back in the
day, one cool thing it did, was...
Pop! OS back in the day, one cool thing it did, was...
Pop! OS back in the day, one cool thing it did, war...
Slackware!
Okay, doch!
Ich kannte bloß das Slackware-Logo nicht!
Ja, Slackware ist die älteste Linux-Distribution, die es gibt.
Die ist älter als Demian.
Und die geht immer noch.
Die hat glaube ich auch keinen Package-Manager.
Der Slack...
Doch, der hat einen Package-Manager, aber ich glaube,
der Slackware-Package-Manager
sind unter der Haube nur irgendwelche Tar-Archive,
die runtergeleitet werden.
Das ist super minimalistisch teilweise.
Richtig, richtig oldschool.
Next, creative and unique,
Slackware is the original
desktop
Linux-Distribution, really.
Ich glaube, Slackware ist die älteste noch aktive
Linux-Distribution, die es gibt.
It's one of the very first Linux-Distributions.
I wanna say it's the oldest active
Linux-Distribution.
It's a little bit rough to work with, though.
The Package-Manager and some of the
weirdness to Slackware,
if you love compiling and building your own programs,
Slackware is cool. There's a lot of
OGs in Slackware. I don't wanna say anything bad
about it, because it is
the OG of Linux-Distributions.
It's just not
my cup of tea.
But I wanna put it there.
Next up is Solus, which has like a
budgie environment, so it's like its own
unique desktop environment. So they're not
really copying much. It's not a fork of
Debian. Solus? Okay.
Hab ich noch nie benutzt.
Of anything, really.
They create their own kernel.
Solus, it's real niche.
There's not a lot of guides on Solus,
which makes it hard for new users
or even intermediate users to use it.
But if you're really familiar with Linux and you love
the budgie desktop environment,
Solus actually does a really good job of keeping up
with these things. And honestly,
there's no forks. They build all their stuff.
So, end-to-end Solus
is kind of an amazing, unique
distribution. Next up is gonna be
SUSE. Okay, please
pointless. Please pointless.
Oder Evil. Evil ist auch okay.
Well, it's in the name.
Ja, okay.
Er hat nicht unrecht. Ich mag
SUSE halt einfach nicht. Trampel, danke
für den Sub. Ich mag
SUSE nicht, man. Ja, es ist...
Aber ganz ehrlich, dann müsste
Ubuntu auch best for business sein.
Wenn SUSE da reinkommt.
Für meinen Geschmack ist
Ubuntu noch mehr...
Naja, gut. Lassen wir's mal.
Es ist Enterprise Linux.
Und es ist gut für Linux.
Ja, für Linux.
Ich glaube, das gesamte deutsche
Regierung hat es schon seit
einigen Jahren benutzt.
Wenn du ein Geschäft bist, brauchst du Unterstützung.
Waren das nicht die mit dem komischen
Terminal-Settings-Menü? Keine Ahnung.
Ich mach einen großen Bogen um SUSE
und jedes Mal, wenn ich damit was zu tun hab,
kotzt es mich an.
Das ist wahrscheinlich einer der,
an die ich anmerken würde.
Sobald man es am Tag für einen normalen
User benutzt, ist OpenSUSE da und
es ist okay. Doch, realistisch betrachtet,
müsste eigentlich
Red Hat bei Business stehen.
Weil das ist da, womit die ihr Kohle machen.
Aber gut, es ist halt...
Letztendlich ist so eine Tierliste ja immer Ansichtssache.
Warum Fedora böse ist, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Wahrscheinlich, weil Red Hat...
...
wie es bei euch ist. Absolut keine Ahnung, welche das sind. Habe ich noch nie gesehen. Welche sind
das? Habt ihr eine Ahnung? Sagt mir alle drei nicht. Void und Zorin. Nobara. Okay. Eventuell
habe ich sogar irgendwas davon schon mal angeguckt. Kenne ich. Sagt mir nichts. Und was ist das? Was
ist das mit dem Vogel? Ist das Nobara? Okay. Zorin haben wir ausprobiert. Okay, wenn wir es
ausprobieren, dann fand ich es wahrscheinlich auch useless, oder?
Kannst du noch auf ein 4680er booten, ne?
Keine Ahnung. Wenn wir es ausprobiert haben, fand ich es wahrscheinlich doof, weil ansonsten
könnte ich mich da dran erinnern.
Haben wir das echt ausprobiert? Kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern. Vor vier Jahren haben wir es
ausprobiert. Okay. Ja, kein Wunder, dass ich mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern kann. Moment,
Moment, Moment. Was habe ich denn da... Sekunde. Was habe ich denn dazu gesagt?
Oder je nachdem, wie man es sieht, ich sage mal leider, sollen sich...
Okay, keine Ahnung, was ich dazu gesagt habe. Was ist MonkaS, Leute? Was ist MonkaS? Was
habe ich übersehen? Einfach nur MonkaS. Ach, habe ich es gesagt? MonkaS. MonkaS.
MonkaS. MonkaS. One try.
Mal sehen, was wir damit machen.
Zeitalter.
Ich habe den Übersetzer wiederartet.
Was sie له, grundsätzlich union.
Und jetzt haben wir...
Hey cocks?
Und.
War.
Wir.
Haben.
Dieses.
Game in Linux,
Nubara is where you should be. So if you're
a gamer in Windows and you're like,
I want to try Linux Gaming,
Nubara is where you go. Because
everything out of the gate is set. You don't have
to know a whole lot about Linux. You can just install
Nubara and go.
It's really a well done
distribution, even though I give it kind of a
knock these days being based on Fedora.
But to be expected, because
Gloria Segril, who makes it,
actually works at Red Hat, so
he knows it the best. And he
does some of the best work.
Stimo S, passiert das nicht sogar auf Arch?
Out there when it comes to Linux Gaming, because
almost anybody that does Linux
Gaming knows about Proton
GE, which is made by Gloria
Segril, which makes Nubara.
And he does all these great customizations
to make Linux
Gaming a thing.
So, this is the Linux
tier list. Let me know your
hate down in the comments below, because I trashed
your distribution. Sorry,
but I want to say,
you get my rationale for each
one of these distributions as you've gone through.
This gives you kind of an idea
of why I put things in certain categories.
And know that this tier list could
look different for you.
And know that...
Also, ohne Mist, ich hätte
das nicht gedacht, aber
ich gehe tatsächlich
bei den meisten Entscheidungen
in dieser Tierlist mit.
Vor allem bei den 2S Tier
Distros.
Just because I don't want people to choose...
Okay, das müssen wir uns nicht mal angucken.
Ja,
so sieht's aus.
Ja, warum Fedora da bei Devil ist,
verstehe ich auch nicht. Ich meine, ich habe keine Schmerzen,
ich mag Fedora nicht. Ihr habt vielleicht gemerkt,
ich mag die meisten Sachen nicht davon.
Fragt man sich, warum
ich eigentlich hauptsächlich Linux benutze, oder?
Ich mag 95%
der Distros nicht und 95% der
Desktops-Environment nicht und eigentlich geht mir das
alles auf den Keks, aber trotzdem benutze ich hauptsächlich
Linux.
Muss an was anderem liegen.
300 Tabs offen. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Tabs? Tabs?
Tabs? Tabs? Ah, hier
habe ich erst wieder fast alles zugemacht.
Ich, das ist, Leute, jetzt, ich kann euch sagen,
deswegen benutze ich Linux.
Das ist das Allerwichtigste.
Läuft bestimmt auch in WSL.
Wahrscheinlich.
Beste. Kennst du
Plinking Lights? Nee.
Oder noch besser,
wenn's ein bisschen
bunter sein darf.
Achtung, Epilepsie-Warnung.
Ach, das Star Wars,
den ASCII, ja, das kenne ich.
Spät. Ja.
Leute, ich krieg langsam Hunger, aber
es ist noch so früh. Es ist erst 11.47 Uhr.
So,
was haben wir denn sonst noch? Zeige ich mal her.
Hatten wir denn nicht hier was?
Raspberry Pi?
Raspberry Pi 5
kann PS2, Wii
und Jubantu.
Ja, gucken wir doch mal, wie gut es jetzt drauf läuft.
Ich mein,
so gut wie auf der
x86-Emulator-Kiste
hier, garantiert nicht.
Allein schon durch die GPU.
Aber mal gespannt.
Kennst du was?
GTI. Okay, die Abkürzung
ist auch für vieles benutzt.
Ich weiß nicht,
was GTI ist und nicht, was
SL ist.
Ach, du meinst,
das Terminal-Programm, der Zug, der da durchfährt,
oder was?
Der Zug, oder
hab ich SL
installiert? Ne, ne, hab ich nicht.
68 Euro teurem
Raspberry Pi 5 laufen Playstation 2,
Gamecube und Wii-Spiele. Außerdem
ein vollständiges Ubuntu-Linux,
so richtig mit Animationen und
allem drum und dran. Und ich kann den
jetzt per Knopfdruck einschalten.
Oh mein Gott. Es gibt nämlich zum ersten Mal
einen Einschaltknopf. Ich dreh durch.
Was? Der hat einen Einschaltknopf?
Man muss ja nicht mal das Kabel rein-rausreißen
die ganze Zeit. Der Raspberry Pi 5 hat jetzt einen Einschaltknopf.
In diesem Video gucke ich mir mal genauer an,
wie sich der Kleinstrechner,
Raspberry Pi 5, so in der Praxis
schlägt, ob sich das Ding als Arbeitsplatzrechner
eignet oder als Spielkonsole
und natürlich, was nervt
im Moment noch. Ich hab den Raspberry 5
eine Woche lang jeden Tag
im Einsatz gehabt.
Düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt.
Liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen.
Jetzt ist Intro, Alter.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert
von S2 Software.
S2 ist ein führendes Unternehmen
im Bereich gebrauchter Software-Lizenzen
von Microsoft und sucht
Reseller. Das Besondere bei S2,
ihr seid richtig 100%
auf der sicheren Seite, denn alle
Lizenzen... Wir hatten ja schon zur Veröffentlichung
des Raspberry Pi 5 ein Video gemacht
und ich hatte euch daher versprochen,
dass wir uns nochmal tiefer in den
Raspberry 5 reinknien. Das habe ich auf jeden Fall
gemacht und nicht nur eine ganze...
Reinknien in sowas ist echt schmerzhaft.
Ich hatte mal so einen Pinheader in der Ferse
stecken. Das ist nicht ohne.
Das ist nicht ohne.
Das war richtig eklig.
Wisst ihr,
dass der...
dass das nicht synchron ist,
wenn es dir in den Fuß sticht
und dass es weh tut?
Also, wenn du dir was in die Ferse
sticht, habe ich gemerkt,
du hörst das und du merkst das,
bevor es weh tut.
Ich hatte wohl irgendwann mal
von so ein paar
Jumper-Kabeln
hier was auf der Erde
wohl jetzt runtergefallen.
Vom Basteln.
Und irgendwann habe ich mich mal mit dem Stuhl
so nach vorne gezogen.
Da macht man die Fersen
auf den Teppich und zieht sich dann
so ein bisschen nach vorne mit dem Stuhl.
Und in dem Moment habe ich die
Ferse hintergezogen, so auf dem Teppich.
Und da lag halt dieses Ding.
Und dann habe ich es auf einmal
gehört von
unterm Tisch, hat es auf einmal gemacht
so...
Weil das hat man ja ein bisschen dickere Haut
an der Ferse.
Und ich habe
leicht den Kontakt gemerkt
an der Ferse.
Und ich habe mir dann gedacht, scheiße,
jetzt tut es gleich weh.
Und das hat dann auch eine halbe Sekunde später weh getan.
Also, sich reinknien in Raspberry Pi
ist wörtlich genommen keine gute Idee.
...woche auf dem Raspberry 5 als Hauptrechner
lag.
...gearbeitet, sondern auch schön
gespielt. Hätte ich das mal besser auf Stadia
gemacht, dann hätte ich den Schmerz schon gemerkt,
bevor ich reingetreten bin.
Da hätte Negativ Latency
wenigstens mal...
Dies gelten ja schon seit Jahren
als ziemlich praktische
Emulation-Spielekonsole. Damit fange ich
jetzt mal direkt an. Es gibt nämlich seit kurzem
eine offizielle Raspberry 5-Version
meiner Lieblings-Spiele-Emulation-Distribution
BatoSera.
Zu BatoSera hatten wir schon mal ein Video gemacht.
Das Raspberry 5 Bato ist noch Beta.
Es wird also auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Wochen
oder Monate dauern, bis alles
richtig durchoptimiert ist. Von der
auch sehr populären Emulations-Distri
RetroPie gibt es übrigens noch
keine Raspberry 5-Version.
Die wird aber auch demnächst kommen.
Die BatoSera-Beta funktioniert erstmal
absolut problemlos. Hat man das
Installations-Image auf MicroSD oder USB-Datenträger
mit dem Raspberry Pi-Imager kopiert,
bootet der Raspberry in Sekundenschnelle
hoch. Also wirklich schnell.
Und natürlich funktionieren alle 8
16-Bit-Systeme
problemlos. Das war aber ja auch schon mal
ein ganz wichtiger Fall. Interessant wird's
ab der 3D-Ära, also Nintendo
64, Sega Dreamcast,
Playstation 2, Gamecube. Ja, der
Raspberry 4 konnte Dreamcast,
auch schon ganz okay und auch viele
Nintendo 64-Spiele klappen da schon
flüssig, aber eben nicht alle.
Das ist beim Raspberry 5 jetzt anders.
Hier laufen auch N24-Problemkandidaten
wie GoldenEye und
Dreamcast auch. Das macht der Raspberry auf
der linken Po-Backe. Guck mal hier,
Crazy Taxi mit 60 FPS und Raspberry 5
so...
Aber was auf dem Raspberry 4
definitiv nicht ging, Playstation 2.
Auf dem Raspberry 5 aber jetzt schon.
Also zumindest in Ansätzen. Richtig
spielbar ist das allerdings noch nicht, aber wie gesagt,
die Bates-Serra-Beta ist auch noch
nicht optimiert. So sieht zum Beispiel
GTA San Andreas auf dem Raspberry
5 zur Zeit aus. Der hat auch 500
Millisekunden-Lag, wenn er was in die Ferse kriegt.
Besser klappt's jetzt schon mit Nintendo Gamecube.
Da würde ich sagen, dass da viele Titel
definitiv spielbar sind. Wir haben hier übrigens extra
das Bild verdeckt, weil Nintendo immer gerne mal
eine Welle macht, wenn hier auf YouTube Emulation
gezeigt wird. Ja, kurz vorm
Aufnehmen dieses Videos ist mir aufgefallen,
sogar Nintendo Wii lässt sich
einigermaßen gut emulieren. Also
Emulation definitiv jetzt schon
besser als beim Raspberry 4. Und da
wird noch einiges kommen. Ah ja, was sicherlich
viele von euch interessiert, die
Raspberry Pi Foundation empfiehlt ja einen
Lüfter für den Raspberry 5. Und wie verhält sich
das nun in der Praxis? Da hatte ich ehrlich gesagt
ein bisschen Angst vor, aber am Ende war ich
dann sehr positiv überrascht. Obwohl
ich den Raspberry immer direkt neben meiner
Tastatur liegen hatte, habe ich den Lüfter
nicht ein einziges Mal gehört. Also außer
bei Ubuntu, aber dazu schon. Ich würde
es tatsächlich, gibt es schon einen
Clear Case
für den 5er?
Easy. Das ist
das erste, was ich probieren würde.
Das ist passiv gekühlt,
aber der benutzt das komplette
Gehäuse als passiven Kühlkörper.
Und wenn man nicht permanent
volle Pulle, Volllast hat für mehrere
Stunden, reicht das in der Regel.
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass es beim
Pi 5 auch reichen wird.
Weiß ich nicht, nicht ausprobiert. Ich gehe einfach
davon aus.
Bei einem Emulator Gaming
Rechner, der ja schon ziemlich ausgelastet
ist, vielleicht auch
für
mehrere Stunden, wenn man daran spielt,
dann könnte ich mir das doch
vorstellen, dass das
vielleicht nicht, dass es nicht verkehrt ist.
Wo sind eigentlich Antivirenprogramme
hin? Ja, Windows Defender.
Da noch mal was. Auch beim Spiele
emulieren habe ich den nicht gehört. Hat sie gekillt.
Ich habe zwischendurch immer mal wieder den Gehäusedeckel
abgemacht, um zu gucken, ob der sich überhaupt dreht.
Aber ja, drehte sich meistens,
aber halt unhörbar. Ich würde also
auf jeden Fall empfehlen, den Lüfter für ungefähr
6 Euro dazu zu kaufen. Ihr müsst jetzt auch nicht,
sondern
eigentlich Angst haben, dass ihr euren Chip
durchschmort. Denn wenn das Raspi
SoC bei hoher Last 80 Grad warm wird,
taktet es sich einfach runter.
Dieses sogenannte Throttling sorgt dafür, dass man
den Raspi auch ohne Lüfter nicht kaputt kriegt.
Aber klar, das kostet natürlich Leistung.
Wenn ihr also nicht wollt, dass euer Rechner
runter taktet, dann doch lieber den Lüfter
benutzen. Ganz konkret brachte der Lüfter
bei unseren Messungen im Benchmark
Geekbench bis zu 11% mehr
Leistung. Ja, und wie ist der Raspi 5
jetzt als Alltagsrechner? Ich muss sagen,
dass ich zuerst das offizielle
Standardbetriebssystem Raspberry Pi OS
benutzt habe, was früher Raspian hieß.
Ja, okay, das kann man benutzen für Alltagszeug,
aber das war ja beim Raspi
4 auch schon so. Also klar,
Internetseiten bauen sich beim 5er Raspi
viel schneller auf, die Gesamtschwubtizität
ist höher. Aber wenn wir mal
ehrlich sind, Raspberry Pi OS läuft
zwar stabil und macht, was es soll,
aber es ist auch nicht sonderlich schön
und komfortabel halt auch nicht.
Also zum Beispiel fehlt die von mir ständig
verwendete Snap-In-Funktion, mit der
man Fenster automatisch... Ey, ich finde auch,
es ist auch, ganz ehrlich, niemand verwendet
das Ding doch wirklich als Desktop, oder?
Wer macht denn sowas?
Pass auf, jetzt gibt es natürlich die Leute, die im Chat sagen,
doch, ich verwende das als Desktop.
Aber nicht so als...
Eigentlich
braucht man die Desktop-Oberfläche auch nicht.
Ansonsten ist das eines der größten Vorteile
vom Raspberry Pi,
das Ökosystem drumherum und die
vielen Tutorials und die vielen Erweiterungen.
Das ist halt der Grund, warum
keiner dieser anderen Raspberry Pi-Clones
das irgendwie ersetzen konnte.
Auch in Zeiten von Raspberry Pi-Mangel.
Oder in viel des Bildschirms
einrasten lassen kann.
Okay, kann ich mit leben, aber was mich echt richtig genervt hat,
die hässliche Textdarstellung
von meinem Lieblings-E-Mail-Programm Thunderbird
und der absolut unübersichtliche
App-Store, also die...
Ja, Font-Rendering unter Linux
ist so ein Ding, wenn man es nicht ordentlich eingestellt hat.
Aber mittlerweile ist es viel besser geworden.
Du brauchst eigentlich
fast keine Font-Config mehr.
Also, das heißt so,
dass was unter Linux die Font-Config macht,
heißt Font-Config.
Wahnsinnig sonderlich kreativ, was die Benahmung angeht.
Du brauchst nur die richtigen
Schriftdaten installiert.
Und wenn du mehrere Schriftdaten hast,
die Priorität richtig.
Aber ansonsten, ich meine, muss man mal sagen,
kann sich hier eigentlich nicht beschweren, oder?
Mein Font-Rendering und so ist echt
voll in Ordnung.
Grafische Oberfläche zum Installieren
von Programmen.
Also, das ist wirklich nicht mehr zeitgemäß.
Und es fehlen halt auch etliche Programme
in den Paketquellen. Also, ich konnte vieles
gar nicht.
Deshalb habe ich mal
Ubuntu ausprobiert. Das gibt es nämlich auch
nativ für den Raspberry Pi.
Das kann man direkt mit dem Raspberry Pi
Imager installieren. Muss man nicht mal
manuell runterladen. Und
wow, was für ein Unterschied.
Das ist wirklich die echte Ubuntu
Gnome Desktop-Umgebung. Also, ohne
irgendwelche Kompromisse. So sieht ein moderner
Desktop aus. Alles bewegt sich so schön
wobbelig. Und hier funktioniert...
Moment, Moment. Wenn sich was wobbelig bewegt,
dann muss es auch wobbly
Windows sein. Leider unterstellt
stürzt kaum was heutzutage noch richtig
gut. Kennt noch einer wobbly Windows von
Compits? Compits wobbly
Windows. Einfach der beste Effekt ever.
Beste. Beste. Viele können
das ja heute nicht mehr. Aber wobbly
Windows, Leute. Das wäre
der Grund, warum ich wieder einen
nicht-Tiling-Window-Manager verwenden würde.
Weil wobbly Windows.
Auch das Einrasten von Fenstern. Also, super.
Außerdem, das Anwendungszentrum ist
viel übersichtlicher als bei
Raspberry Pi OS und hat auch viel mehr
Software zur Auswahl. Ihr müsst allerdings im Hinterkopf
haben, dass wir hier auf armen Architektur
unterwegs sind. Nicht auf x64.
Das heißt, dass das Softwareangebot
auf normalen PCs natürlich noch mal
besser ist. Aber was man so im Alltag braucht,
das findet man auch hier. Leider hat
das Raspberry 5 Ubuntu zur Zeit noch
einen fetten Bug. Wenn ihr den Lüfter verwendet,
dreht der unter Ubuntu immer mit vollen
Umdrehungen, was richtig laut ist.
1,5 Tonne haben wir im CT.
Ubuntu hat dafür wahrscheinlich einfach nichts
zur Steuerung. Mit diesen Befehlen hier
findet ihr auch in der Beschreibung, könnt ihr den Lüfter
wieder auf die unhörbare Stufe
1 schalten. Ja, also, generell
hat mir das richtig Spaß gemacht, den Raspberry
5 mit Ubuntu als Alltagsmaschine
zu verwenden. Ging echt alles
super. Also, zum Beispiel auch irgendwelche Tonaufnahmen,
mein USB-Audio-Interface
wurde problemlos erkannt, Videokonferenzen
mit Teams, auch prima. Das einzige
und das ist natürlich blöd
als YouTuber, YouTube ruckelt
ab den 80p, vor allem bei
Lass mich raten, warum YouTube ruckelt.
Könnte es vielleicht das
sein, was ich immer gerne so als Beispiel
bringe, was unter Linux schiefläuft?
Könnte es vielleicht sein, dass der Hardware-Decoder
nicht verwendet wird?
Ich will jetzt nicht wieder damit
anfangen, weil das musstet ihr euch von mir
schon hunderttausendmal anhören.
Ja, aber Hardware-Video-Decoding
ist echt ein Problem unter Linux.
Du brauchst, ich meine,
mittlerweile geht es halbwegs,
bis es halt nicht geht, wie man hier sieht.
Du brauchst halt echt die richtige
Kombination aus
Mesa-Treibern, Browser-Versionen,
Desktop-Versionen, Grafik-Treiber-Versionen,
Grafik-Karte und dann funktioniert
teilweise auch nur ein Codec und dann
hört mal wieder VP9 auf zu funktionieren
und es ist grottenschlecht.
Der hat einen Hardware-H264-Decoder,
der Raspberry Pi.
Videos mit 60 Bildern pro Sekunde.
Beim häufiger gebräuchlichen 30 FPS-Standard
geht es so gerade eben, würde ich sagen.
Ein paar Frames werden hier aber auch noch
gedroppt. Das sieht man, wenn man mal mit
rechts klickt, die lustige YouTube-Funktion.
Statistik für Interessierte anklingt.
Richtig safe klappt es leider nur mit 720p.
Das ist schade und liegt halt daran, dass
der Raspi ganz wenige Hardware-Video-Decoder
eingebaut hat. VP9, das ist der Codec, den YouTube...
Der hat einen... Achso, stimmt!
YouTube hat standardmäßig VP9.
Das ist richtig. Dann, ja gut, das wird er
nicht haben. Man kann aber mit einem
Browser-Plugin YouTube forcen, das
H264 zu verwenden. Da wäre ich
gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
YouTube zur Zeit primär verwendet hat er
zum Beispiel nicht, H264 und WebM auch nicht.
H264 hat er doch. Moment, ach Moment,
Decoder, vielleicht hat er ja auch... Ach, der
hat nur einen Encoder und keinen Decoder?
Moment, ernsthaft? Was, aber H265 hat er?
Ist das nicht sonst umgekehrt, ja? Moment, er
hat einen Hardware-H265... What? Das muss irgendeine
Lizenzgebühr-Issue sein. Was? Das muss irgendeine Lizenzgebühr-Issue sein.
Was? Das muss irgendeine Lizenzgebühr-Issue sein. Ja, doch, er hat doch einen.
Er hat doch einen Hardware-Decoder. Okay, keine Ahnung,
blickt man nicht durch. Wahrscheinlich
funktioniert das wieder nicht, aufgrund
der vorher erwähnten Sachen, dass da
wirklich die... Moment, wirklich? Hat er nicht?
Raspberry Pi ist nur Hardware-Video-Encoder
und... Wirklich? Okay, was auch immer
anscheinend...
Genau genommen gibt es nur einen
Hardware-Video-Decoder und das ist H265.
Das ist ein... Wirklich? What? Populärer Codec für 4K,
das heißt, wenn ihr den Raspberry als Wohnzimmer-Player
mit Kodi oder so verwenden wollt, dann solltet ihr keine Probleme haben.
Und wenn der Raspberry 5 nichts anderes macht, als Videos abzuspielen,
dann reicht auch die reine CPU-Leistung für das ruckelfreie Abspielen mit
nicht-Hardware-unterstützten Codecs. Aber halt im Browser, in YouTube, ja, da sind
halt auch noch viele andere Dinge zu tun und da kommt der Raspberry dann an seine Grenzen.
Sehr merkwürdig. Komplett ruckelfrei in 1080p60 habe ich YouTube nicht zum
Laufen bekommen, also auch nicht mit so Wordpress,
Workarounds wie Embedded YouTube-Seite oder Abspielen in Voll-C.
Aber wie gesagt, als reiner Medienspieler, also ohne dass da ein Desktop mit Browser
und so noch dazuläuft, funktionieren die gebräuchlichen Video-Formate ruckelfrei.
Wichtige Sachen noch. Wenn ihr viel auf dem Desktop machen wollt,
dann nutzt als System-Datenträger keine Micro-SD.
Schaut mal hier, das sind meine Messwerte mit Raspberry Pi OS auf Micro-SD.
88 MB pro Sekunde lesen, 32 MB pro Sekunde schreiben. Und das hier ist eine USB-S.
Ah ja.
Drei...
Klar.
360 lesen, 252 schreiben. Das ist also ein riesen Unterschied.
Und ja, der Raspberry 5...
Dafür hängt dann halt noch was zusätzlich da rum.
...auf Wunsch auch von USB-Datenträgern. Noch eleganter ist natürlich eine ins
Gehäuse eingebaute NVMe-SST. Die unterstützt der Raspberry 5 theoretisch auch,
aber dafür braucht man noch so ein Adapter-Board, das wir bislang noch nicht testen konnten.
Mein Fazit...
Finde ich gut, dass sie das jetzt aber haben.
Also, der Raspberry 5 ist ein super spaßiger Computer.
Vor allem...
...wenn man die klitzekleine Größe und die Leistungsaufnahme von nur 3 Watt im Idle und 9 Watt bei Volllast bedenkt.
Aber die große Frage, die ihr auch immer in den Kommentaren stellt, warum sollte man sich im Jahr 2023 überhaupt ein Raspberry 5 kaufen und...
Wegen dem Ökosystem.
...vielfältig keinen gebrauchten Thin Client.
Ja, also für Emulator...
...kein Raspberry Pi.
Für Netzwerk-Storage...
Ja?
Für irgendwelche Desktop für die Oma...
...auch kein Raspberry Pi.
Was ich...
Wofür ich ein Raspberry Pi kaufen würde, ist wenn ich irgendwelche Bastelprojekte...
...hätte.
Oder im Keller irgendwas laufen lassen will.
Ja, dafür ein Raspberry Pi.
Auch wegen dem Ökosystem, gerade auch was Hardware-Erweiterung angeht.
Schließlich kommen zum Platinenpreis von 68 Euro für ein Raspberry 5 mit 4 GB RAM...
...auf jeden Fall noch 13 Euro für ziemlich spezielle Netzteil dazu...
...und bei den meisten wohl auch noch Gehäuse, Lüfter, Micro-HDMI-Kabel und System-Datenträger.
Ja.
Und System-Datenträger.
Ja. Und System-Datenträger.
Da ist man dann ganz schnell deutlich über 100 Euro...
...und für den Preis kriegt man gebraucht einen viel leistungsfähigeren Thin Client.
Ja, und hinzu kommt noch, während ich das hier aufnehme, gibt es in der gesamten deutschsprachigen Welt keinen einzigen lieferbaren...
Nur so kleine Projekte kannst du auch in ESP nehmen, es kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel einen Raspberry Pi im Keller stehen.
Daran ist ein...
Da ist so ein Ding dran angeschlossen.
So ein Ding dran angeschlossen.
Ja, da kann man das irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht größer machen...
...weil es die Seite übelst sagt.
Da ist so ein Board angeschlossen.
Und meine Kabel abgezweigt von meiner Tür-Gegensprechanlage, weil ich anhand von dem Analog-Digital-Wandler, wie viel Spannung da anliegt, erkennen kann, ob einer geklingelt hat oder nicht.
Das machst du halt mit nichts anderem.
Also du könntest dir das auch mit dem ESP32 basteln, das würde an der Stelle funktionieren.
Aber zusätzlich habe ich da dran noch USB für die Steuerung von der Heizung.
Zusätzlich habe ich da dran noch USB für die Steuerung von der Heizung.
Das machst du nicht mit dem ESP32.
Das ist für mich das optimale Kombi-Gerät im Keller unten.
Liest die Tür-Gegensprechanlage aus, ob geklingelt wurde und kann die Heizung steuern über USB.
Wobei die Heizung nicht direkt USB hat.
Die Heizung wird über zwei Infrarot-LEDs gesteuert, wo es das offizielle Kabel vom Hersteller allerdings nur gibt als USB-Variante.
Man könnte mit sehr viel Mühe sicherlich beides basteln.
bumper dann herbschppers
border
Skills
функ verdade
buttons
perfekt für den anwendungszweck das aber glaube ich auch noch ein raspberry pi 3 sogar der da
der da läuft die kamera das ist wifi die ist einfach so da und strom dran per usb die da
macht der raspberry pi nichts mit die eu was wie die eu eigenständig windows 11 besser gemacht hat
asiat bing rausgeworfen ok naja windows kann ja es kann ja eigentlich fast nur besser werden das
ist doch so cheap aid oder das brauche ich jetzt informatik vorlesung von einer halben stunden die
empfehlung immer okay das hier geht ja noch rich people buy watches genau das wollte ich heute das
interessiert mich brennend was verdient ein koch
ok zeit mal her was was für die denn ein koch wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich zu wenig und es
ist ein übelst anstrengender job koch ist echt anstrengend also ich weiß dass aus um zwei ecken
mein vater hat koch gelernt aber nicht lange als koch also später eine andere sache aber ich habe
ich ja erzählt was dafür für scam sachen getrieben hat früher nicht als koch danach das ist echt
anstrengend koch knochen job ja stichwort octopus das kann man ganz schön so sagen dass wir dann so
mit drei abender schlafen
steht oder vier auch gefühlt bis ich zufrieden gestellt zum immer ich bin immer froh wenn klasse
im hintergrund läuft die ist nicht copyright monka toss muss noch einiges passieren auch
geheizt technisch ja ich bin ich las 27 jahre jung und ich arbeite als kopf und stern hotel
strandperle und zwar genau da hallo meine vier räume
und ja die küche eigentlich nur ein durchgang was heißt nur für mich reizt persönlich weil kochen
durch auf arbeit sowieso genug mein job als koch ist wirklich behauptet sehr stressig ja
ich mir vorstellen weil ich anstrengend ist das ist wirklich anstrengend du hast sehr viel stress
du nimmst die arbeit auch teilweise mit nach hause natürlich ist es in anderen jobs wahrscheinlich
auch so aber du hast halt immer so dieses ja morgen morgen morgen und die feiertage und menüsplan und
was da in die karten spielt also ist nicht nur das kochen tatsächlich hatte mir vorstellen
auch ein job die nicht machen wir wollen würde und auch nicht können genau das finde ich halt
schön und ein toss toss toss ton musik hallo morgen jetzt heißt es erst mal arbeitsplatz aufbauen
wir haben so ein putzmittel oben er hat ja nicht nur tausend tonnen arbeit sekarang gäbe es killi ab
Ey, der hat von hinten, von hinten dieses Schwitzenhalter-Ding, sieht ein bisschen aus wie aus Uncharted.
Der sieht von hinten auch so aus, nur dass er kein Koch ist.
Das packen wir einfach so an, so einen Scoop da rein, vermischen das mit Wasser und dann haben wir cleane Oberflächen.
Genau, da braucht man jetzt keine Gedanken sich machen, ob das vielleicht auf die Hände geht oder ob das halt...
Okay, für mich heißt das so viel wie viermal Bratkartoffeln anstatt Kartoffelsalat und einmal eine Hokkaido-Suppe.
Ich bin verantwortlich für die Gemüsebeilagen, die Sättigungsbeilagen und auch für jegliche Suppen aller Art.
Genau, das ist jetzt für Mittag. Mittags haben wir auch eine Karte und die geht bis, lass mich lügen, 14.30 Uhr.
Also wenn man ehrlich zueinander ist, dann kann man sagen, okay, das raubt einen.
So ein bisschen die Vorbereitungszeit, dann hast du es halt schwer, nebenbei noch die Vorbereitung für heute Abend zu machen.
Vor allem, wenn du dann eventuell noch alleine bist, im schlimmsten Fall.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Mach die Musik aus, Alter.
Okay, was ist? Realschule am Schluss, Ausbildung zur Fachkraft für Lebensmitteltechnik.
Alter, die Sachen haben heute so ultra-advancede Namen, Mann.
Höhere Handelsschule in Fachwirtschaft, Ausbildung zum Koch.
Okay.
Er hat festgestellt, BWL-Shit hat er keinen Bock drauf.
Kann ich nachvollziehen.
Hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Ihr wisst, ich hab's auch ausprobiert.
BWL-Kram, bleibt mal bloß weg, ey.
Toss, toss, toss, toss, Moment.
Toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, okay.
Macht der Internet-Historian jetzt Videos auf Deutsch?
Ach nee.
Packen wir das mal ein paar Bracke drauf in die rein.
So.
Ja.
Ich find das geil, wie der sich das alles merken kann, ey.
Oder da filtert wahrscheinlich jeder nur das raus, was für ihn relevant ist.
Kein Highspeed-Internet, ich bin gedrosselt.
Kein Highspeed-Internet, ich bin gedrosselt, okay.
Ist da jemand bei Vodafone vielleicht?
Die könnten mal ein bisschen weniger Monka-Toss-Musik machen, Alter.
Toss.
Fertig.
Jetzt können wir uns gerade mal kurz entspannen.
Und.
Schauen, was wir alles für heute Abend gucken, dass auch alle Herdplatten aus sind.
Das Frühstück ist immer mit drin.
Und die Gäste können dann noch das Halbpensums-Menü dazu buchen.
Das variiert halt immer aus vier unterschiedlichen Kategorien.
Also heute gibt's Salatbuffet, Vitero Tornado.
Ja, blablabla, genau, asiatisches.
Ja, aber da bist du doch auch.
Der ist doch in acht Stunden nicht fertig, wenn er in der Küche ist, von morgens bis mit.
Und mittags erst und dann abends, der ist doch, der ist doch 15 Stunden in der Küche.
Zwiebelrasparen brauchen wir in der Wurzel-Gemüse, geschwenkte Bahnhöhle mit Chimian-Schampion-Rahmen und dazu resiniertes Ofen, Tomaten.
Ja, genau.
Deswegen, ich schreibe jetzt nochmal alles auf, auf einer Liste, das sind die Sachen, die wir jetzt gleich alle zu tun haben.
Wok-Gemüse steht drauf, das müssen wir produzieren, das ist für das zweite Menü.
Gemischter Reis, da haben wir noch Wildreis im Kühlhaus, meine ich, müssen wir noch Reis eventuell dazukochen, das dann einmal vermengen, ein bisschen Butter dabei, dann in Timbal-Form abfüllen.
Glasiertes Wurzelgemüse, müssen wir einfach Gemüse putzen.
Zurechtschneiden, turnieren heißt es und genau, Kartoffelstampf machen, gegebenenfalls Kartoffeln, kochen, mehlig kochende für Kartoffelstampf, Kartoffelchips, vorwiegend festkochende nehmen oder festkochende sogar am besten sogar noch, Bandnudeln, genau, schauen, ob welche da sind.
Oh, Chat, wo wir gerade beim Essen sind, ich kriege übelst Hunger, ratet mal, was es heute gibt, ihr kommt nicht drauf.
Champignons müssen wir schneiden, da müssen wir einen Rahmen machen, das einmal abwinden, die Champignons rein, genau, Chimian, den zupfen wir einfach später ab.
Nudeln mit Lachs, richtig.
Korrekt.
Und schmeißen dann in die Soße rein und ja, genau, die Ofentomaten.
Alter, BR, hört auf mit Toss-Musik, man, das kann man sich doch so nicht angucken, da muss ich immer sinnlos rumlabern, dass Twitch die Musik nicht erkennt, Mensch, jetzt aufhören, kein Toss.
Die haben, die haben keinen Bock.
Oh, Whirlpool.
Ich würde sagen, die ist aufgekocht.
Also, wenn du alles nacheinander machst, dann kommst du da zeittechnisch, glaube ich, nicht bei rum.
Ja, das ist halt, glaube ich, die Kunst, die es dann auch am Ende des Tages ausmacht, dass man halt viele Sachen gleichzeitig gut macht.
So, ich hole jetzt noch Petersilie.
Das sieht, das in der Landschaft vor dem Zugucken ist das mega anstrengend.
Die müssen wir noch hacken für den Posten und Thymian, das müssen wir gleich noch in die Soße reinmachen von dem, oder von der Thymian-Rahmensoße und wenn ich den da habe, dann kümmere ich mich kurz um die Tomaten und bis dann.
Bis gleich.
Feiertage sind für mich eigentlich gar nichts Besonderes mehr.
Also, das klingt jetzt vielleicht übel, aber man ist es einfach gewohnt.
Man ist gewohnt, an Feiertagen zu arbeiten und ich bekomme auch jetzt hier in meiner Position Feiertags- und Sonntagszuschläge und deswegen habe ich noch weniger Schmerz, wenn ich, sage ich mal, Feiertags- oder Sonntags arbeiten muss.
Das sieht jetzt sehr fest aus, aber wenn wir das später erhitzen, dann ist es gar nicht mehr so fest.
Oh, lecker.
Lecker.
Wollt ihr probieren?
Ja.
Das ist schon das Grinsen.
Und?
Riecht's gut?
Chefskiss.
Brotgemüse haben wir, gemischten Reis haben wir, glasiertes Wurzelgemüse haben wir, Kartoffelstampf haben wir, geschmackte Bandnudeln haben wir da, Thymian-Champion-Rahmen haben wir da, gratinierte Ofentomaten sind gratiniert oder schon verbrannt.
Lass mal schauen.
Ne, geht klar.
Sehr gut.
Können wir auch rausnehmen.
Und, ja, dann haben wir alles.
Zumindest.
H.P.
A la carte.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich bin gespannt, wie die Sitzverteilung ist.
Ob jetzt gleich alle auf einmal kommen.
Weil, äh...
Das eben war, glaube ich, schon das Durchschnitt.
Ja, ja.
Dann kann ich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so frei reden wie jetzt, weil ich mir dann Sachen mehr merken muss.
Ja, Weißwein.
Am stressigsten ist es, wenn tatsächlich alle auf einmal kommen.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Dann wird es gemütlich auf den Herdplatten, weil du...
Ich würde sagen, wenn du mit 8 Armen gefühlt am Posten stehst und sehr viel, ja, parallel machen musst.
Und da muss noch was Gescheites rauskommen, weil...
Schmeckt...
Wie lange brauchst du noch?
Kannst du anfassen.
Ja.
Zack.
Beim Sauerbraten en place eine kleine Drei.
Ja.
Beim Sauerbraten.
Das ist dann irgendwann so dieser Automatismus.
Dann macht man...
Da musst du aber echt wissen, wo alles steht, ne?
Und ich meine, das ist super krass.
Wenn die fertig sind um, keine Ahnung, 22 Uhr,
dann müssen die ja noch eine Stunde aufräumen, dass das morgen wieder...
Ey, boah, das stelle ich mir echt heftig vor.
Die beiden Vieren, die Eins können wir schicken, oder?
Das ist schon mal ein Essen zurückgegangen.
Sogar noch gar nicht so lange her, um ehrlich zu sein.
Das war jetzt vor einer Woche.
Dann waren die Gäste so außer sich, weil sie meinten, das wäre überhaupt nicht abgeschmeckt gewesen.
Wo ich mir dachte, hm?
Aber okay.
Das habe ich zur Kenntnis genommen.
Und ja, man nimmt es sich natürlich so ein bisschen zu Herzen, aber...
Ja, manche...
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, du hast richtig Abfahrgäste auch,
die aus Prinzip rumstenkern müssen und die auf den Keks gehen,
einfach nur, weil sie denken, sie können es jetzt.
80 Essen, die er am Abend hat, oder 90 oder 100 oder auch mehr,
und sich dann ein Gast beschwert,
dann ist die Quote, glaube ich, trotzdem noch weiterhin sehr gut.
Halleluja.
Ja, ich muss mal kurz das Kühl aus.
Zop, zop, zop.
Äh, brauche ich kurz noch... Ja, gib mir zwei.
Ist das okay?
Ich habe es vielleicht anbrennen lassen.
Aber nur vielleicht.
Das sieht so stressig aus, schon beim Zugucken.
Was ist... Okay.
Da hat sich einer beim BR heute ausgetobt, ja?
Im Herzen ja.
Auf dem Papier weiß ich es noch nicht.
Also, da bin ich ganz ehrlich,
weil das ist schon...
Das ist schon ein Knochenjob.
Und da muss man dann am Ende des Tages für sich entscheiden,
ob man das sein Leben lang machen möchte oder nicht.
Und Stand jetzt würde ich es machen.
Wenn es mehr Kohle gibt.
Jetzt steht eigentlich nur noch Sauermachen an.
Bist du?
Ja, wenn das Geschäft durch ist, dann...
Habe ich doch gar nicht so schlecht geschätzt.
...gibt es dann Lockeratronen in der Küche.
Dann haben sich alle wieder lieb.
Und dann quatscht man, schnackt man.
Was gibt es Neues? Was hat man erlebt?
Und sowas, ne? Also quasi so dieser...
Die zweite Familie.
Ja.
Sieht so anstrengend aus.
So.
Ja, Messerset ist wahrscheinlich sowas wie beim Friseur das Scheren-Set.
Da hat jeder so sein Spezialding.
Ist das auch wieder crispy clean?
Ich verdiene brutto 2700 Euro.
Mit Sonn- und Feiertagszuschlägen so im Durchschnitt 2790 Euro.
Und das sind unterm Strich...
Das ist halt...
...netto 1930.
Das ist halt jetzt echt nicht...
Wenn du das wahrscheinlich auch nur mal zwölf, ne?
Das ist jetzt halt echt netter Wahnsinn.
Für so, wenn man sich überlegt, wie stressig das ist.
Guck mal, das ist, wenn du es mal zwölf rechnest.
Moment, wie viel hat er?
Sonn- und Feiertagszuschlägen so im Durchschnitt 2790.
Okay, sagen wir mal 2800 mal zwölf.
Ey, das ist echt...
Boah.
Und selbst wenn es mal 14 ist, ist das nicht viel.
Das ist echt nicht viel.
Und das sind unterm Strich dann netto...
Also...
Ich...
Also ich würde es eh nicht machen.
Erstens nicht können.
Und bei dem Stress nicht wollen.
Aber dann dürfte es doch wenigstens...
Der verdient viel zu wenig.
Dem sollten...
Was heißt dem sollten sie?
Dem müssten sie viel mehr bezahlen.
Werden sie nicht machen, weil das wahrscheinlich dann...
...so sich für die wieder nicht lohnt.
Aber das ist halt echt wenig.
Für das, wie anstrengend das ist.
Ich bin sehr ehrgeizig.
Für mich gibt es immer noch einen Schritt weiter.
Bis ich zufriedengestellt bin, muss noch einiges passieren.
Also auch Gehaltstechnik.
Auch Gehaltstechnik.
Natürlich.
Das ist...
Dafür hätte ich echt keinen Bock.
Auf Trinkgeld würde ich...
Oh ja, ja geil.
Kommt da ein bisschen was oben drauf.
Man muss keine Steuern drauf bezahlen.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Aber trotzdem.
Ich würde mich so nicht verlassen.
Weil das halt auch immer schwankt.
Freu dich einfach über das, was du kriegst.
Wenn es 70 Euro sind, freust du dich über 70 Euro.
Wenn es 200 Euro sind, über 200 Euro.
Und wenn es 500 Euro sind, dann freust du dich über 500 Euro.
Heute lief gut.
Also ich könnte jetzt nichts bemängeln.
Bis auf, dass ich einmal den Rotkohl anbrennen lassen habe.
War eigentlich alles...
Doch, war alles gut.
Für mich lohnt es sich definitiv.
Ich habe Spaß bei der Arbeit.
Das Team passt.
Der Arbeitsweg ist sehr entspannt.
Und ich bin gut.
Letztendlich ist es ja gut, dass es ihm gefällt.
Und Spaß macht.
Das ist auch nicht unwichtig.
Also für den Stress dürfte es doch ruhig ein bisschen mehr sein.
Geld.
Und muss jetzt nicht irgendwie am Hungertuch nagen.
Und das ist das...
Ich meine, er bezahlt nicht viel Miete.
Aber trotzdem.
Was für mich zählt.
Doch, ich glaube schon, dass das anspruchsvoll ist.
Ich glaube, was es da anspruchsvoll macht,
ist nicht so sehr die einzige Sache für sich betrachtet.
Sondern die Kombination da drauf.
Die Kombination da draus.
Und du kannst ja auch nichts verkehrt machen.
Du kannst nicht sagen, ach, ich installiere mal kurz neu oder so.
Wenn es mehr wäre, würden sich die Leute beschweren, dass es mehr kostet.
Ja klar, die Leute beschweren sich eh immer.
Ich meine, mir ist schon klar, wie sowas zustande kommt.
Aber da müssen sie sich nicht wünschen, wenn es beispielsweise weniger Nachwuchs gibt.
Weil das ist gerade in der heutigen Zeit, wo es ja in den letzten paar Jahren
auch noch so mega teuer geworden ist an vielen Stellen.
Alter, die Musik. Toss, toss, toss.
Aber immerhin, guck mal.
Gleich mal in den ETF-Plan stecken.
Er hat halt auch nur wirklich wenig Miete.
Manch anderer bezahlt 1000 plus Miete, je nachdem, wo du bist.
Aber trotzdem, also für den Stress echt nicht ohne.
Sag ich mal danke fürs Zuschauen.
Und hoffe, dass ich euch heute ein paar charmante Einblicke in mein Berufsleben...
So, ihr Lieben, ich hoffe, ich konnte euch heute ein paar charmante Einblicke...
Aber...
Scheint ein echt netter Kerl zu sein.
Leck mich fett, Junge.
Das ist ja so schrecklich.
So, Lieben, ich bedanke mich fürs Zuschauen.
Und hoffe, dass ich euch heute ein paar charmante Einblicke in mein Berufsfeld geben konnte.
Und hier findet ihr noch die Moneymaker-Doku in der ARD-Mediathek.
Und hier findet ihr noch weitere Folgen zu Lot sich das.
Und die werden nicht verlinkt.
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Aber was ein Pfleger in der Notaufnahme verdient, verdient wahrscheinlich noch weniger.
Wobei ich gehört habe, dass du als Pfleger, wenn du flexibel bist,
mittlerweile gar nicht schlecht verdienen kannst.
Also mit flexibel ist gemeint, wenn du bei irgendeiner Zeitarbeitsfirma bist
und dort einspringst, wo Leute gebraucht werden.
Dass das echt ganz gut sich bezahlt wird, ja.
Boah, das geht doch klar.
Das kann man sich geben.
Schade, dass das nicht so viele Leute machen können, wie bei uns in der IT.
Ich sitze gerade hier und streame.
Und habe passives Einkommen, quasi.
Ohne in die Gruppe zu kommen.
Weil ich dieses Wochenende Bereitschaft habe.
Und allein für die Verfügbarkeit, dass ich das Handy hier liegen habe, kriege ich Geld.
Also insofern...
Da muss ich nicht in die Telegram-Gruppe für passives Einkommen.
Ich muss einfach da sitzen.
Aber man muss sagen, dieses Wochenende war echt schon ein bisschen stressiger.
Es war gestern was, hat mich einer angerufen.
Und...
Heute Morgen um 6.30 Uhr kam eine SMS.
Das ist richtig, richtig, richtig doof.
Dass irgendein System im Monitoring keine Daten mehr empfangen hat.
So, dann logge ich mich ein.
Heute Morgen um 6.30 Uhr.
Gucke drauf.
System läuft, sieht gut aus.
Ja, SMS.
Und...
Wir werden alarmiert über unterschiedlichste Wege.
So, gucke ich rein.
Der Checkmk-Agent ist irgendwie im Arsch.
Okay, nice.
Neu gestartet, immer noch kaputt.
Aber Server geht noch.
Habe ich ins Ticket reingeschrieben und...
Ja, was soll ich machen?
Können sich am Montag die Leute, die sich mit dem System auskennen, drum kümmern?
Ne, Ticket war schon auf.
Ich habe ins Ticket was reingeschrieben und bis Montag...
Ne, für mich nicht.
Ich habe Urlaub jetzt.
Ich habe Urlaub.
Bis nächstes Jahr.
Hast du dir das ganze Jahr sonst keinen Urlaub genommen?
Richtig.
Tägliches Streams.
Ne, vor allem...
Ja, mehr Streams und vor allem mal wieder ordentliche Videos auf YouTube.
Ah ja.
Irgendwo muss das ja hin.
Ich habe jetzt quasi dieses...
Diese Bereitschaft am Wochenende ist echt das letzte, was ich mache dieses Jahr.
Nächste Woche noch zwei Tage habe ich noch ein Teambuilding-Workshop.
Aber letzter Arbeitstag, wo wirklich was gemacht wird, war am Freitag.
Du hast aktuell drei Tage Woche, weil so viel Überstunden.
Exzellent.
Ja.
Ja, ich bin weg bis Januar.
Ah, du weißt ja, wo du mich vorstellst.
Ich finde es.
Wie viele Urlaubstage hast du?
24.
Ich arbeite nur 80 Prozent, also bekomme ich nicht 30, sondern 24.
Ja, deswegen mache ich das nicht.
Dazu müsst ihr erst mal Videos hochladen.
Meine Einkommen über YouTube und so ist echt nicht die Welt gerade.
Und da ich die letzte Zeit auch recht unregelmäßig gestreamt habe...
Auf Twitch ist aber okay.
Aber da war auch schon mehr.
Aber ich mache das ja nicht, um krass Kohle zu verdienen.
Trotzdem habe ich natürlich nichts gegen freigewordene Prime-Subs.
Warum machen wir die vor immer aus?
Weil ich habe übelst Hunger.
Dann baller jeden Tag zwei...
Nee.
So viel fällt mir doch gar nicht ein, dass ich zwei Tage ein Video raus...
zweimal am Tag ein Video rausballern könnte.
So viel...
Keine Ahnung.
Nudeln mit Lachs könnte ich zweimal am Tag rausballern.
Ja.
Ich esse jetzt aber Nudeln.
Reactions.
Oh, nee, Alter.
Das ist...
Ich finde, die meisten Reactions sind so useless.
Also, wenn überhaupt, dann muss es halt auch irgendwas sein, wo ich ein bisschen was dazu sagen kann zusätzlich.
Ja, zum Beispiel das Reacten auf irgendwie eine Linux-Tierlist oder so.
Aber da brauche ich den Tyler, der das zusammenschneidet.
Weil wenn ich ein 27-Minuten-Video gucke, labere ich eine Stunde.
Das ist zu lang.
Kochvideo.
Quatsch.
Blödsinn.
Juckt doch keinen.
Oder wahrscheinlich würde das sogar Leute gucken.
Ja.
Das ist ja das Schlimme an Reaction-Videos.
Die schlechtesten und langweiligsten Reaction-Videos werden trotzdem massig geguckt.
Verstehe ich gar nicht.
Aber nee, das wird zu doof.
Na klar.
Immer.
Weißt du.
So geplante Sachen machen bin ich ja das beste Beispiel für.
Ich setze ja immer geplante Sachen zeitnah um.
Wie man auch die letzten Jahre über gesehen hat.
Wie ist das eigentlich bei Teilzeit?
Ist es da wichtiger zu schauen, dass man einen Tag nimmt, der weniger Feiertage im Jahr hat?
Ja und nee.
Also ich habe Montag.
Montag ist glaube ich mit der schlechteste Tag, den man haben kann, was Feiertage angeht.
Weil sehr viele Tage auf Montag, also Feiertage, standardmäßig auf Montag fallen.
Trotzdem finde ich persönlich Montag am sinnigsten.
Weil montags sind sie alle noch super motiviert aus dem Wochenende und es passiert total viel.
Montag ist immer stressig.
Und für das, was ich am Montag machen will, ja auch mal mich, war zumindest der ursprüngliche Plan, auch mal mit ein paar Sponsoring Leuten für YouTube unterhalten, die haben montags auch noch richtig Bock.
Also Montag ist für das private Business der beste Tag, was zu machen und der stressigste Tag auf der Arbeit.
Deswegen habe ich Montag genommen.
Auf der anderen Seite könnte man das auch komplett kleidzeitmäßig machen und halt dann nehmen, wann man will.
Aber ich habe Montag fest.
Was ich ganz gut finde.
Da wissen alle, montags bin ich nicht da.
War bei der alten Arbeit so, war bei der Arbeit davor so und bis bei dieser Arbeitsstelle, also bei dem Job genauso.
Montags.
Kann man eine Ausbildung noch später beginnen?
Ja.
Das kommt davon, das hängt davon ab, ob du einen Betrieb findest, der dich nimmt.
Du kannst, ich glaube du kannst, du kannst theoretisch, theoretisch kannst du sogar irgendwann Anfang des Jahres oder so noch einsteigen.
Dann hast du gerade in der Berufsschule ein bisschen was verpasst, aber Berufsschule ist eh komplett useless.
Ähm.
Aber wichtig ist halt, dass du einen Ausbildungsbetrieb findest, der das, der Leute sucht, ja.
Die meisten suchen halt, die haben schon gesucht.
Bei den meisten fängt man halt zum 1.9. oder zum 1.8. und zum 1.10. und meistens zum 1.9. an.
Ja, dann.
Ich brauche mehr Views.
Die letzten Videos liefen echt gut.
Okay, das allerletzte nicht so, aber das dachte ich mir schon, das war ja übelst random Video.
Aber ich, also eins muss man ja echt mal sagen.
Ich habe wirklich, also mir geht es da wirklich nicht, nicht schlecht auf YouTube.
Die Videos haben, wenn man sich mal überlegt, wie lange ich schon auf YouTube bin.
Wie, was für Sachen ich früher gemacht habe, was ich jetzt mache.
Ich habe enorm viele Videos, die teilweise 50k, 80k und sowas knacken.
Fast 70, 50, so 80.
Und das ist echt, also das ist definitiv nicht Standard.
Vor allem bei meinem Upload Pensum, ja.
Also ich finde es lustig.
Also ich finde es läuft echt nicht schlecht.
Views, was denn sonst?
Welches Video ist das mit den weißen Views?
Naja, das kennt ihr alle.
Das ist dieses sinnlose Video, wo ich durch den Schnee laufe in meinem Garten.
Warum auch immer, das hat über 2 Millionen Views.
Guckt mal, beliebt.
2 Millionen.
Das zeigt überhaupt nicht mehr die richtige, den richtigen Viewcount.
Ah ja, 2, 2, 2,1 Millionen Aufrufe.
Das ist so sinnlos, Alter.
Nur YouTube, nur YouTube versteht, warum dieses Video durch den Algorithmus so gepusht wurde.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe auch keine Ahnung.
Es gab doch schon V2 und so.
Ich bin schon ein paar Mal durch den Wald gelaufen oder so in Schnee.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das so gut angekommen ist.
Ja, ich habe ein paar Videos, was auch über 100k hat.
Also es schwankt natürlich mit dem Thema.
Was ich gut finde ist, dass...
Es ist ja gar nicht mehr so viel Gaming-Content, weil ich eben nicht mehr selbst aktuell so viele Spiele habe, auf die ich Bock habe.
Und insgesamt muss man echt sagen, auch der Nicht-Gaming-Content wird erstaunlich viel geguckt.
Was ich nice finde, was mich jetzt bestärkt dazu, noch ein bisschen mehr in der Richtung zu machen.
Das Emulator-Video 80k.
Ähm...
So, dass ich Windows-Notebook auf der Arbeit habe.
50k.
Die fiese Ausbildung.
Das war tatsächlich ein Reaction-Video.
Auf, ähm...
Technikeller.
Teilzeit-Video.
Leichter Clickbait-Titel, gebe ich zu.
Aber es ging ja im Prinzip trotzdem darum.
Ja.
Na gut.
Okay, Leute.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Drei Stunden.
Vielleicht...
Vielleicht machen wir nachher noch ein bisschen weiter.
Mit der Streaming-Anwendung.
Wir müssen ja die ganzen Krustentiere erfreuen, die jetzt neu reingefollowt haben.
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Jawoll.
Oder vielleicht auch was anderes.
Vielleicht machen wir noch was anderes.
Vielleicht auch nicht.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, wie es heute Mittag läuft.
Ob ich da...
Ob ich Bock drauf habe, noch online zu kommen.
Oder nicht.
Kommen wir mal.
Alles klar, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
CU.